[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
It's the final day of the air things
monsters and we're getting the Grand
Final between the two biggest stars in
online chess Hikaru Nakamura versus
Magnus Carlton we are of course hoping
for another Armageddon battle and I'm
now gonna have our experts in the studio
Place their bets so what they think the
winning bid for time in a potential
Armageddon will be so no peeking here
and Robert what's the strategy here well
they're playing chess we've seen Mattis
Carlson Bluff I think today they're
going limbo how low will they go I think
the answer is quite low
well what a day we have ahead of us a
big welcome everyone to the final day of
the air things monsters and the
Champions chess tour
I'm really looking happy with himself
the king can't move wait wait wait wait
wait this move is breaking the rules
whoa everything under control but
suddenly the position has changed this
just looks glorious Big Choice from
ordinary guys there we go if you have a
lunch continues
[Music]
there's a big threat on the board Magnus
Carlson is furious it's going straight
for the kill Wesley so has blundered
he's blundered his Knights white king is
trapped this is
Magnus Carlsen showing his genius
and again Magnus Carlton will have to
show his genius because he has a top
task ahead of him today a grand final
against Hikaru Nakamura and to safely
guide you through all the action today
we have our experts in the studio Grand
Master David Howell International Master
Tanya sachdev and Grandmaster Roberts
and David there's actually been involved
on chess.com seems like Magnus Carlsen
is a big favorite in the Grand Final do
you agree uh not necessarily I think
this is going to be tougher than it
should be on paper the reason that I
feel so many viewers have voted for
Magnus Carlson is because he has already
that lead he's won a match and Hikaru
needs to beat him twice in two matches
in order to take the title but uh I do
feel that it is Hikaru Nakamura he will
have a chance okay Tanya what should we
expect from this Grand Final between
these two this is the most epic rivalry
of modern chess of our times Kaya we've
got the classical rapid and Blitz World
Champion and the Triple Crown Magnus
Carlsen up against who is the best ever
speed chess Specialist of all times
Hikaru what can we expect the one one
thing is for sure no quick draws every
game is going to be a big fight Hikaru
is going to maximize every single chance
on the board and what are the chances
Robert we will see armaged on today do
you think I think quite High because
neither of these two has won a match in
regulation so to speak because Magnus he
beat origin and then ikaru in Armageddon
and akaru he lost a Magnuson Armageddon
and then beat Wesley yesterday it's all
been Armageddon yeah and are you
confident about your bid no
I have the experts predictions in here
I'm going to keep them in here until we
have a potential Armageddon and we're
asking you at home as well to place your
bin what do you think will be the
winning bid for time in a potential
Armageddon One winner will get a signed
air things device and actually today
there is a special sale on air things
you get a hundred dollars off your air
things wave plus you can just get this
QR code and you're directed into the
page where you can get your air things
device to monitor air quality in your
home and air quality is important for
chess players especially when they are
playing at home day four yesterday we
had we started out with the losers
semi-finals which was a battle between
Wesley Seoul and Arjun aragaisy to go
through to the losers final
I really like the way Arjun is playing
Wesley show is capable of playing
energetic Dynamic style but he's forced
into it in this game that's a sacrifice
he's just I think
he's incredible assuming he had to
defend his Rook move his Rook or swap
the Queens he says no just take my Rook
please he moves out of check and that's
a mark of Genius Wesley so now we see
the position repeat itself Wesley so go
through to face Hikaru Nakamura and the
loser is final we're off it's the
Italian game this is what Wesley has
been going to it's his go-to opening I
do feel like this position is so solid
for Hikaru and there we have it the car
missed it look at a car's face he looked
to the side he was oh what is that and
he realizes that now he is going to face
a terrible ending while Queen and Rooks
on the board but a horrible Pawn
structure that was a missed shot from
hikara wow now oh could you have swapped
Queenstown oh yeah your car saw it
immediately and he's shot oh my God
it's a draw they've repeated the
position three times but Wesley could
have won he could have won if he didn't
trade the Queens off what the final move
was a blunder by Wesley so we should be
500 what it's happening guys yo-yo
between the queens and it's over we have
a draw we're going to Armageddon look at
Wesley so inching in with the queen
Nexus King is coming up to B4 he is
kicking Black's pieces back the guy was
shaking his head he hates his position
he hates what he's trying to defend look
how the black queen is just causing a
nuisance from behind here so many
weaknesses in Wesley's Camp Nakamura
needs just a draw and it looks like
Wesley might have missed a huge
opportunity his head Wesley now it's
only 15 seconds in it this is just easy
for hit car right now and he's even
ahead on time right he doesn't have any
problems whatsoever Hikaru he knows he's
got this in the bag he's smiling he's
got a Time advantage and he clenches his
fist Wesley resigns Nakamura makes it
through to the ground finally he will
face off against Magnus Carlson
and also in the studio to guide us
through this final day of the air things
Masters we have international Master
Ivanka houska and Hikaru Nakamura even
if it's been down on the loser's bracket
he's actually unbeaten in the tournament
he's really getting the hang of this
format iwaka yeah the fullback seems to
suit his resourcefulness I would say and
I also have to say that he just has
Thrust out the Armageddon bidding
because you know he did it perfectly
against Wesley so twice incredible now
the Grand Final with Magnus cross and
Annie karonakamura in division one is
not the only Grand Final happening today
in the air things Masters also in
division two two players will face off
in a grand final Fabiano Corona and you
Yang Yi so do we have a big favorite in
this matchup Ivanka I mean it has to be
Fabiana Corona who just needs to win
this match in order to take home the
first place in division two and also
secure a spot into the next divisions in
the next tournament exactly he has a
tough job ahead of him he needs to
defeat Fabi twice which is really big
ass because Fabiano has been winning all
his matches well just three games what
kind of a grand final should we expect
in division two with these two players
well it will be kg I think Fabiano will
be of course be trying to lock things
down just keep it as solid as possible
meanwhile you Yang Yi who has to be that
agent of chaos he has to up destabilize
Fabiano and you're gonna to keep us up
to speed on everything happening in this
Grand Final throughout the day Ivanka
and let's take a look what's at stake in
the air things monsters a total prize
fund of 235
000 the winner of division two gets ten
thousand dollars fifty tour points and
qualifies for division one in the next
event the winner of division three was
actually decided yesterday and some
Savion winning that got 55 000 and 24
points top three in division one are
guaranteed spots in the next event and
The Winner Takes home thirty thousand
dollars and 154 points that's gonna be
either minus Crossing or Hikaru
nakamuran we actually already know three
out of eight players in the next event
in the Champions you mentioned two big
names you know you have Magnus we have
Hikaru throw in Wesley and now we could
potentially throw in Fabiana Carona or
Yu Yang Yi is already insanely strong so
the next one is just gonna be on fire
already looking forward to it now two
days ago Magnus Carlsen Annika Nakamura
they faced off and the winners finally
are in the air things Masters let's take
a look at what happened in that match oh
there we go it started this is the
winner is final he goes for the more
ambitious approach wow that is making
intentions very clear shots fired very
surprised I've got to say that Hikaru
looks so poker faced on the camera
because I would be terrified here for
black how do you get that white porn it
must be so frustrating Hikaru knows he's
about to make a draw and finally we see
it wow here we go look at Magnus he
quickly responds with Knight F6
challenging that Rook on its place and
now that Rook is really oddly praised
are we gonna see a repetition again are
we gonna see Bishop B3 Queen F5 Bishop
C2 it is happening we are heading arm
again
we've got liftoff
that's a big blunder yes because there's
a tactic Knight takes Pawn on E5 that is
a game changer oh he doesn't find it he
moves his Knight away look at the
evaluation bar dropping down in Black's
favor those are two Runners and Hikaru
is he gonna try and flag Magnus the
answer is no it's a draw hey Cara is
actually the one who offered a draw
that's the ultimate sign of respect that
is a good show of sportsmanship Magnus
Carlsen wins the winner finals with a
draw
and a big smile on his face there Magnus
Carlsen and how much of a mental win
what's that David winning actually the
bidding in the Armageddon it was huge
not only did that Armageddon game decide
their match but uh just that one second
difference the smile that uh kind of was
a vote by both of them Magnus Mel is
living in hikaru's head a little bit and
if we come down to another bidding
that's the only chance maybe the first
chance that Hikaru will get to exercise
those ghosts let's take a look at the
two players rolled here to the Grand
Final we started out with quarterfinals
Magnus and Hikaru both won their matches
in dominant fashion magnets against
Serana and Nakamura against Young dukesh
and the winner is semi-finals Magnus
knocked down Eric icy to the losers
bracket but bangers he did lose one game
in that match Hikaru Nakamura he
eventually won a tight battle against
Wesley so and then Magnus he did win
their winners Final on Wednesday
knocking Nakamura down to the losers
final where he once again faced off
against Wesley so and once again it went
all the way to Armageddon where Hikaru
Nakamura won the bidding and with the
black pieces he got the results he
needed so here we are in the Grand Final
we might have a short and intense day
but it could also be a long day Robert
what are the regulations there for the
Grand Final yeah we have a minimum of
three games because if Magnus carlsa
Comes Out Swinging it takes down the car
first of two and a half points wins it
in the first match with best of four if
a car Nakamura takes down Magnus we get
a repeat a second match a best of two in
that one so that could be four games in
the first one plus Armageddon two games
the second match plus onion we have a
maximum of eight games and it'll be
super exciting yeah Hikaru has to win
the first match Tanya will it affect the
way he plays a hundred percent we're
going to see a completely different math
strategy by Hikaru now there are two
things at play here first Hikaru has to
make sure that he forgets about the fact
that he needs to beat Magnus twice to
win the championship he has to just
focus on leveling the score leveling the
field in this first set in fact if he
goes on to do that Kaya he will perhaps
become a favorite for that second set
we've seen him throughout the tournament
so far to go for the match chat of just
draw happy with that take you to the
Armageddon believes in his ability in
that and then crushes opponents there
but that's not going to work against
Magnus he has to make the most of every
single opportunity no quick draws go for
the wins with the white pieces all right
it's Norway against the US and the Grand
Final of their things monsters but
Magnus he's also playing from the North
American continent visiting his uh
chessboard friends in Canada yesterday
was a day off for Magnus he did post on
Instagram yesterday
definitely enjoying himself at the
sports club playing chess and watching
some sports so he didn't reveal to us
David two days ago what he would do on
his rest day but do you think he's
coming in relaxed and happy today yeah
Magnus is certainly very relaxed
certainly very happy and uh knowing him
he took his mind off chest maybe doing
some exercise and I should say quiet
rest days in chess I'm not always a good
thing you do break your flow you do
break the Rhythm sometimes and
especially when you're playing well you
want to keep going so let's see whether
Magnus can keep up that good form he
showed before yesterday's day off could
it actually be Advantage Hikaru he's in
the flow he played yesterday yeah it was
a tough match so you're in the flow of
Chess as you're saying you're thinking
chess Non-Stop and that can help you
instead of breaking the pattern where
you just have a day off your mind is off
elsewhere watching sports so I do think
that playing every day can be very
helpful in the tournament of this
magnitude yeah there is no doubt these
two are very even in the faster time
controls uh in the speed Chess
Championship in December Hikaru won
their battle in a very exciting match
and you commented on that Robert can you
describe that much that commentator's
curse aside where Magnus blunder the
bishop that was the start of the match
Hikaru jumped out to a huge lead Magnus
stormed back but when all was said and
done it was just a little too much
Hikaru Nakamura he won by one point the
timer ran out on Magnus Carlson's
comeback hikar nakamur was the deserving
speech as champion and only about a week
later they played again and the Blitz
World Championship that was a draw
Magnus eventually though took the gold
medal and as we know in the most recent
battle here in the air things monsters
winners final Magnus won that one so
what will it take for Hikaru today uh
again Kai all comes down to the kind of
opening prep and the fighting spirit
that Hikaru shows not having that math
strategy of going into the army getting
Maxima maximize your chances in every
single game now even in this event yes
Magnus beat Hikaru but Hikaru didn't
actually lose a single game they had
five draws Hikaru has been unbeaten so
far Magnus Carlsen hasn't lost a single
match but he's lost one game in the
process to Arjun aragasse uh there was a
time back in the day when Hikaru had
this huge mental block against Magnus
Magnus had a crushing score but he has
overcome that in fact in 2022 Hikaru did
not lose a single game to the world
champion wow wow that is some amazing
stats we are waiting for the first game
in the Grand Final to start this is the
head-to-head stats between them in Rapid
Blitz chess wow that is a lot of games
and it is Advantage Magnus David wow Kai
I'm trying to do some quick maths here
but uh I'm struggling that's a huge
amount of games and Magnus does have a
significant lead
91-51 I was expecting it to be closer to
be honest but uh this isn't taking into
account the recent history which as
Tanya mentions isn't necessarily so
one-sided Magnus maybe small advantage
on paper but uh Hikaru making ground and
uh here we go we're about to start game
one Magnus with the white pieces looking
very slick there and uh I think he'll
try and come out all guns blazing if he
can as well he doesn't want to just uh
take a solid approach it's not his style
first time in a long time I feel we've
seen Magnus Carlsen actually comb his
hair can that be it I'm gonna make my
hair quality jokes
the hair things mustard
well we do know Magnus Carlsen he has
good air quality air things is
monitoring the air quality in the room
he's sitting in Canada sometimes though
opening his window to get some fresh air
he is going to need perfect air quality
today his mind needs to uh really work
because Hikaru Nakamura is the toughest
opponent you can face off against in
online chess and rapid and speed chess
waiting for Magnus to make his first
moves any predictions he buys for the
first game
I'll uh I'll steal the most likely first
move one E4 I'm going for one D4 okay
feel out of options now I'm about to go
Knight F3 just because they took the two
most popular moves I'm Kaya well I think
Magnus uh wants to get a mental
Advantage here and maybe shakiro with
something strange which I don't know B3
B4 oh yeah he's done it before yeah he's
uh he's gone for that opening but uh we
see okay air quality not so great to
start the day you should open his window
maybe yeah we've seen Magnus literally
open his window after a loss against
Eric icy earlier in the tournaments
maybe he was aware that his air quality
was affecting him maybe feeling a bit
stuffy in that room oh and it was the
English opening and I was expecting you
to guess that one so close I did get it
right there was no E4 D4 or Knight F3 he
starts with the pawn in front of the
bishop and moves it two steps ahead but
we might see a conversion there yeah so
a transposition it started as an English
opening it can transpose into the
Queen's gun but declined especially if
white lifts is Queen spawn now we're
back in the Queen's Gambit declined via
a uh different route and okay which
variation will Hikaru choose he's played
pretty much everything in this position
he normally keeps solid just develops
the black Bishop one square the black
Dart Square Bishop gets castled and then
solves his problems a bit later but
Hikaru looking off to the right now just
uh choosing just uh deciding what to
play against Magnus I'm sure he's
predicted this he's played it hundreds
of times Hikaru but
deciding what Moody's in yeah it's a big
day in the Champions Chester we have the
very first Grand final of the season and
we really really want you guys to join
in and hang out with us here in the
studio you can share your thoughts your
questions for our experts in the studio
either on Twitter using the hashtag
chess Champs or in the twitch chat we
will pay attention to that as well thank
you for being with us on this big day in
the Champions chess store and let's have
some fun I feel like we've said our
favorite Pokemon Magnus and card do the
same in the chat probably has to get
involved with that as well we're talking
about Chess but Pokemon has been a theme
throughout the event definitely and guy
are you were saying let's have some fun
take a look at the position on the board
David we were looking at lines where the
bishop can develop but Hikaru chooses
none of that he goes for the most
dynamic option of picking up that
Central Pawn sacrificing that beep on
this is a mess on the board what is
going on yeah so this is a known
variation but I haven't known Hikaru to
dabble in this one too much normally he
chooses is a very solid approach there
we see Magnus push upon for it so the
Queen's Gambit accepted it's a kind of
branch of that now showed Hikaru
grabbing a pawn he's given a pawn back
but not the typical Pawn uh that you
would see black offer in most variations
here black has really ugly structure on
the queen side doubled C pawns isolated
a pawn but he has a really juicy Outpost
for his Knight in the middle of the
board and whoever races out gets
developed first tends to get the
advantage here I've always slightly
preferred White's chances you get more
space you have the more fluid structure
but black as Tania said very Dynamic and
Hikaru clearly choosing this opening
because of the match situation is part
of his strategy to imbalance things and
maybe even go for a win as black uh
Robert what do you think of this uh of
this plan I've always been a fan of this
opening because it is so Dynamic black
has these doubled isolated pawns on the
sea file we see the one next to the
queen and the one sticking out pretty
far on the C4 square that said as David
was matching the D5 square is firmly
under Black's control there's not a
white Pawn that can challenge the square
and Black's light Square Bishop will
slide onto the Phoenix diagonal and take
control over the board's longest line so
this is going to be good news for Hikari
and Castle queenside his King will be
safe there despite the advanced pawns
and that D4 Pawn is a bit tender in
White's position all that being said the
double eyesight C pawns remain
weaknesses sometimes they get picked off
and that could spell some trouble for
Hikaru so it's a double-edged position
chances for both yep definitely chances
for both but if this one does start to
turn around hikaru's turning things in
his favor then Magnus might start to get
nervous a loss with white and the whole
momentum the whole initiative of the
match would change so Magnus here just
developing his Queen both sides staying
very very flexible Hikaru here if he
wants to keep Magnus guessing might
develop his bishop and say okay I might
go this way I might go the other way
depending on what you do but uh as
Robert says it is very typical in this
type of position to commit to going
along towards the queen side and it's
surprisingly hard to attack black King
on that flank these Black Knights act as
fantastic guardians of that King and if
they protect it then it's going to be
very hard for Magnus to find a plan
quite often uh really interesting start
to this game I'm loving it this is what
we came for and we're getting action
from the word go as we've been talking
just how Dynamic this position is David
we don't know which side Hikaru wants to
put his King on will it be on the king
side or the queen side either ways
there's going to be danger white can
also look at certain Pawn breaks on the
queen side with moving that beep on one
step ahead and Magnus stops it forever
with his La hecaro stops it forever with
his last move he jumps the Knight
forward the one weakness that white had
created with that eight push is the B3
square that is where the Knight has
headed we've been talking about not
making intentions clear with the black
king and look at hikaru's uh last move
there is no Queen side castling anymore
Hikaru is going for the attack for the
initiative along the b-file yep later on
he'll clear some pieces out the way and
then a big Target on the B2 Square
backward point long term so this does
mean that both sides may be intend to
Castle on the king side and uh we'll see
if either side can attack on that flank
later and you were mentioning about
clearing the way one possible plan for
black to do that is Step Up with the
bishop do that C6 Square uh David and
then you want to bring your knight let's
see if we can bring up the analysis
board in a bit but it's a very nice idea
with that last move making sure that you
can attack the beat upon the knight from
B6 then can jump up to A4 offering some
trades taking away the pieces from
White's Queen side and the play will be
about flag attacks yeah flank attacks
and uh this point will be under uh under
watchful gays here and also as Tanya
mentions this would be a nasty skewer if
this does happen so hikara's plan what's
he gonna go for is he just gonna move
his Bishop out the way and Castle Safety
First approach or will he go a bit more
aggressive and start Landing blows
already on that side of the board
um really interesting starts and uh yeah
did you expect this Robert I must admit
I thought Hikaru would just try and hold
with black and pressed with white but he
hasn't been pressing hard with white so
far this tournament and wow I think
we're both shocked by this last minute
yeah you asked me expectations I wasn't
quite expecting the pawn push it does
make sense you're just saying are you
sure you want to Castle kingside for
Hikaru because your Castle there white
is going to launch an attack uh your
initial question did I expect opening
absolutely not I expected the type of
opening though because Hikaru Nakamura
has said this in the past and so many
other players have as well that a lot of
people are afraid of Magnus Carlson and
that helps him win games that
psychological Edge Hikaru is not afraid
he knows how good Magnus is we saw their
headset record Hikaru has lost maybe
more games than anybody to Magnus
Carlson but he's also beating him
perhaps more times than anybody else has
so he is ready to bring the fight to
Magnus and he plays Tanya's move Bishop
C6 the Knight May slide out next as
we're showing in some previous lines but
perhaps Magnus Carlson is going to take
a page out of uh was it gukesh's book
sliding his King one square over instead
of castling he will lift his Rook later
but for now he might the slightest King
to the side yeah and talking of good
cash of single cash played this idea of
pushing the pawn forward in this exact
opening this exact structure multiple
times but uh also your point Robert who
beats Magnus Carlton once let alone 51
times and that's just rapping in Blitz
chess and that's just official
tournaments they've played plenty of
course online and uh kind of friendly
matches as well so
um yeah imagine beating Magnus 51 times
and still having a uh a losing record
wow
incredible stats you know I think in
sporting history we've always got these
epic matchups and these great rivalries
that go down in history books if we
think about boxing there's Muhammad Ali
versus Joe Frazier and their big fight
more recent history there is Pedro
versus Nadal and their battles on Court
and when we think about speed chess
today and in the future when we will
talk about speed chess these are the two
names that will come to our mind their
fight it will be Magnus Carlton and
Hikaru Nakamura incredible yeah it's uh
it's like Messi and Ronaldo after their
after their picture recently where they
literally acted as these two with that
position across the board from one of
their epic battles I think in no HS a
few years back I can't remember who was
Missy who was Ronaldo but either way two
greats two guys this was uh Ronaldo
picked the Magnus position and Messi had
the Hikaru position so how lucky Ronaldo
and Messi are to get to uh be Magnus and
Hikaru that's one way of putting it for
sure but uh no this was and it really is
a messy one and yeah
it's very nice but it is the type of
position that a car wants against Magnus
we saw in their first matchup in the
winners final that Magnus was getting
these slight pulls a car's position was
not very Dynamic he had to sit and wait
for what Magnus was trying to accomplish
and here Picard says none of that Magnus
you had the day off yesterday perhaps
you weren't looking at chess and I was
he prepared this line and look at Magnus
he's saying all
steam ahead let's go push that pawn
forward H5 maybe that pump will go for
it even further to H6 just try try to
create a dent in Black's king-size
structure all that said and Black's play
is very quick with this Knight A4 jump
the B2 Pawn is already under attack so
Magnus has his work cut out for him and
he needs a solution to this move this is
clearly part of her current nakamura's
plan right now to launch an attack on
the queen side and I'm not seeing it
immediately I've got to admit uh how we
comfortably defend this Pawn I don't
really want to for example drop the
bishop back to defend it that would make
a very sad piece of the white bishop and
uh if not then black has a serious
threat Rook Chase Pawn remember as Tanya
pointed out Knight takes Knight is not
really feasible unless you want to
sacrifice material knowing Magnus he
would be okay with sacrificing I've seen
him sacrifice far more for far less in
return but yeah right now it's so
Dynamic so many tactics already in the
player's mind and we're only at move 15.
they play Fast up to this point but
they're going to go into the tank for
longer because it is so messy so chaotic
as sad as it might seem I think David
you just cannot drop that B2 Pawn so we
might see a retreat with that Bishop
that you were pointing out and we do see
an attack on both sides the queen side
is where hikaru's got his forces the
king side is where Magnus is trying to
rush down with that H Pawn so it really
incredibly dynamic position and very
often with these top players in chess we
see that their moves make sense when you
look at them backwards the plan that
Hikaru shown on the queen side and we
were talking about the Knight jumping
onto A4 to clear the B file but Hikaru
has something else in mind he decides to
force a trade-off and create an
imbalance by exchanging the bishop for
the Knight wow interesting decision I'm
very biased towards my Bishop so that
wasn't even on my radar at all these top
players they know when to make
exceptions when to kind of forget their
prejudices and uh yeah now this queen
trade what do we think should we have a
vote are the Queens coming off
if you've gone white can't go for a
queen trade because let's take a look at
this if you do go for the queen trade
the Knight picks it up and now the B2
Pawn is just super vulnerable David this
would be bad news for white because
notice how the rook and the Knight two
attackers currently zero Defenders you
might just end up being a pawn down in
this end game yeah and uh therefore
we're assuming magnets to dodge the
queen trade I'm just wondering how
because there are downsides uh there are
drawbacks to every Square you want to
put this queen on if you move it for
example one square forward you might get
hit by a knight if you slide to the side
you might get hit by the other night
um ideally you want to use the Central
Square but then you're abandoning the
whole of your queen side to their fate
and these pawns will drop off maybe you
can go in under attack switch Focus to
the other flank but commit or decision
now for madness but a very Magnus move
would be to trade Queens not by caption
we keep talking about this okay you've
asked the question and so has the chat
when do you trade pieces you do it on
your own terms so The Rook can slide
over one square and say let's trade on
C2 that looks a lot better because if
the Queens come off the board now that
pawn on C4 is under direct attack by
black can't just force uh Focus all of
his forces on the B2 Pawn because both
the knights are needed to defend this
Pawn on C4 I actually think this would
be an advantageous position for magnets
so I don't think a car really wants to
trade the Queens he would only do it
under favorable circumstances and that
would be landing his pieces very quickly
up the queen side okay that's important
just everything on your own terms you
know what your opponent wants you know
what you want but you have to make sure
that uh it's only uh in circumstances
that favor you and uh Magnus going into
the tank thinking now about level time
if Magnus did take the black queen right
now would Hikaru then take back with a
black knight and have both his Knights
on the rim wouldn't that be kind of bad
for a car I think in general it's not a
great idea but right there just
specifically and concretely it's because
White's B2 Pawn would drop off there's
no way to say that as Tanya was pointing
out so you're right Kaya normally you
want to strand your opponent's Knights
on the side of the board especially when
you have strong Bishops as white does
but uh Robert predicts it correctly you
can allow a queen trade but on your own
terms there the Black Knights would have
actually been surprisingly strong
we've got this move that Robert was
suggesting and my heart's beating really
fast because uh guys what happens if the
Black Knight jumps on to B3 you gotta
move that Rook away the Knight falls
back The Rook comes back the Knight
comes forward we might see a little
dance do you think there is a potential
for a repetition here oh wow
predicted it before we've got two
prophets here in the studio Tanya and
Robert and the Knight has jumped in
hitting this Rook if the Rook moves
black does have the opportunity to slide
back second time we've seen this and as
Tony is also mentioning The Rook moves
the night moves might be three on the
board David but the Rook slid the other
direction so Magnus is saying let me
just show up my weakest point that pawn
of B2 is exactly what black is going
after and now the Knight Retreats the
queen can in fact Dart to the center of
the board and over to the king side
because you protected your weakness The
Rook looked more active on D1 but this
is a position that calls for defense
then switching into offensive gear I
like what Magnus is doing here and you
get sense by hikaru's time management
he's starting to think and his hands on
his head he knows that this is a big
moment and he can't just go back and
forth because Magnus is not going to
repeat yeah really nice move there and
not intuitive at all but again that's
why the top players are so good they're
happy to play Passive moves if they
really need to they know when to be
flexible when to go on the attack when
to be active when to sacrifice but also
when to take a time out to just hold
everything together and I saw Hikaru on
Twitter he called it Groundhog Day
playing Magnus yet again do you think he
fully believes in his chances uh today I
just love How brave he's been in this
opening a hundred percent I mean just
the way he's been playing he knows what
he needs to do to win this match he
needs to beat Magnus not once but twice
and while it's a start the kind of
position that he's gotten extremely
Dynamic now he gives a check he gives
the check doesn't fall back with the
Knight and look at the way he's playing
such aggressive moves every move is a
piece forward just incredible stuff
Hikaru knows that level one today is to
First create chances in the first set
not to think about that final reset that
he will get and I think he's done
everything right with the black pieces
it's not easy to get this kind of a
position against Magnus Carlsen yeah
it's a cliche right you take it game by
game move by move but that's what Hikaru
has to do he is taking significant risks
however he's playing very aggressively
but he has abandoned his King side
Magnus takes the opportunity to step
forward now watch out in any end game
that y H Pawn is very close to promotion
the number of times I've seen Magnus
promote his AOH pawns after marching
them forward this far and only now does
Magnus clarify the central tension he
trades off for porn uh also the black
king wants to castle at some point it
can't stay in the center forever it
blocks uh the connection between the two
Rooks so when uh when Hikaru eventually
does Castle uh to the king side his King
will always have mating threats against
it with this structure but what about
Magnus what is his plan with his King
his King is gonna have to stay put for a
little bit but that C4 Pawn that's the
tender one uh black got rid of one of
his double isolated pawns and he might
lose both he traded off the one that was
less Advanced now the one that was
sticking out might just fall so I think
Magnus he's not thrilled about his
King's placement but there aren't black
forces aiming at it right the King has
so many of those minor pieces keeping it
safe and sound so the C4 point I believe
is going to drop next maybe it's
premovable at this point yeah it's
almost premium ball unless your opponent
plays a really surprising move and
attacks your queen or something but uh
yeah Robert so no matter how black
recaptures this Pawn he's temporarily
down upon uh we're expecting him to take
this one back if he takes with the
bishop or with the Knight the two most
logical moves You're Expecting uh this
one to suddenly drop off so let's say
Knight takes Pawn white recaptures and
not only have you won a pawn suddenly
threats on the board
actually you're right maybe it is that
simple right now do you think Hikaru is
just misjudged something here
miscalculated or is there a way to
justify uh going down upon that when
someone offers a trade and then after
that piece is taken they start thinking
it feels like they might have
misevaluated the sequence of events so
Hikaru is probably trying to figure out
how to deal with this because if we just
go down this line for a second yes the
pawn structure will probably be
compromised after a knight takes Bishop
a queen takes Knight and then Bishop
takes E3 here but there are all sorts of
threats the queen can go up to C6 with
check preventing black from castling uh
that King is actually getting hunted
right away if the king slides over the
queen just goes to D6 with check and
hits The Rook winning the game on the
spot maybe this is what Hikaru
overlooked because otherwise he would
have a reasonable position but the queen
delivers that fatal check and The Rook
will be hanging at the end of the day
yeah you're right Robert maybe he just
assumed that Magnus had to recapture
this bishop now the black king gets time
to run to safety and uh White is left
with uh ruinous Pawn structure
especially these two weeks long term I
do slightly prefer white here but uh at
least black has a decent share of the
chances okay he's gone for this line so
we might well see after Bishop takes one
Magnus just recapture just go Pawn up
and threats against the black king
looking uh very very shaky for mikaru
right now down two and a half minutes as
well uh let's see whether he finds a
solution Magnus didn't take that pawn
yet surprising I've got to say but uh
still looks like a decent position he
trades off Bishops instead and there we
go he beat me to it I was about to say
normally having an uncastle King is a
problem because your Rooks aren't
connected but here it doesn't matter
White's Rook is able to get up the board
and start attacking across and uh very
effectively it was a sick tactic here
like let's bring up analysis report
because if black tries to defend this
pawn and C4 it's under attack three
times you want to bring a pizza you
bring your knight back to A5 white
pushes this Pawn up to B4 normally you
could take on Busan it is a legal move
but you'll notice that the pawn is the
only thing blocking the Queens from
staring at each other so if you take
onpassan here you actually lose your
queen on C5 and if you don't take that
pawn on Plus on you're losing a knight
because there is a fork so The Rook H4
is especially clever just going right
after the C4 Pawn Black's Knight is
unable to retreat that spells trouble
for a car knock more he is going to go
down upon this position yeah really
sneaky and the only other way to defend
it is to shuffle your Rook across in
here I guess as Magnus Carlson you can
just take this Pawn anyway so the
tactics are too twofold there and after
the night we catch the bishop now you
take the other Knight and you've got to
pawn ahead maybe this is uh damage
limitation this is what Hikaru needs to
do at some point try to get your king
castled but suddenly the tactics all
working out in White's favor and that's
a red flag that's a bad sign when all of
these two three movers are working in
your opponent's favor you need to start
panicking you need to start just trying
to control things
all right well remember everyone we do
have a competition for everyone today if
we end up with Armageddon what do you
think will be the winning bid you can
tweet your answer using the hashtag
chess Champs and the one who gets
closest will win a sign air things
divide signed by Magnus Carlsen are
experts in the studio have also placed
their bid I have them safely in my
envelope did you play some bid by the
way I didn't play some videos you can't
be wrong
[Laughter]
I like it that way just having your fate
in my envelope currently it looks like
it's a Carlos page right because this
position we've been praising his opening
approach and just what a mess he created
but now it just looks like it's somewhat
backfired a little bit because he's down
on the clock by almost five minutes
already barely out of the opening which
means that the biggest questions are
still to come and still to be answered
the C4 Pawn Under Fire as we can see the
Queen the bishop and the The Rook all
three pieces hitting it and very
importantly black cannot just shift The
Rook defend it because regardless of
that perhaps we can just really quickly
show this line that you were pointing
out David where if black defends it with
the third piece and I see that Hikaru is
reaching out for his Mouse he's about to
make a move then white can't pick up the
C4 Pawn with the bishop you pick it up
with a knight and the Knight on B3 hangs
so he would have lost the pawn anywhere
and instead Hikaru decides to First
bring his King to safety but the big
question always in this position is how
safe is that King look at that pawn on
8-6 imagine at some point White's Queen
lands on F6 once it gets there the queen
on F6 these dark squares that are super
weak there will be a mate on G7 that
you'll have to watch out for for the
rest of the game black needs to be
extremely careful white picked up the
pawn Hikaru has gone to move that Rook
pinning the bishop but can the Knight be
picked up on B3 I think it can and it
most likely will and uh the only
question here for Magnus is which way do
you capture you could take this Knight
with your queen allowing the Black
Knight to jump in and this is a superior
version of what we looked at earlier for
black because suddenly both your Rooks
are active suddenly all of your pieces
really really well placed and uh okay
looks like we've gone in the other
direction sorry just to backtrack after
Bishop takes I was expecting Queen takes
Queen here I've got to say and heading
into an end game but white would have
had an extra Pawn instead Hikaru gives a
really sneaky check hitting the white
king just in time Magnus is able to go
and block with his Queen his Queen was
also Under Fire and now the bishop Falls
and this is the current position White's
the report up yeah I think we're
expecting that Queen trade because the
activity black would have received but
the problem with Black's position is
this Pawn on H6 it's not just trying to
deliver a Checkmate right now even
without Queens on the board we could see
a future with his back ranked Checkmate
threats and that's bad news for hikaru's
King and that is probably why he cars I
need more pieces on the board but with
those pieces on the board and we just
see a magnus's rook slide across the
beef for hitting the queen protecting
that extra pawn and that pawn is ultra
well defended and now magnets continue
to improve his other pieces watch out
for hikaru's King but for now he is
quite active trying to create threats
against the White Queen side yep I'm
expecting uh just to block this open
file as you mentioned some threats later
on of getting the Rook behind so block
this open file place your knight on a
really nice square and for example if we
do see a rook trade at least you have an
active Rook here threatening this Pawn
in conjunction with your queen you have
a very well placed Knight and for now it
looks like you've got an element of
control
um still upon down however still maybe
uh preference for white but uh you're in
the game and David exactly this line I
think it demonstrates Robert's idea so
well that hair black is hitting with the
rook and the Queen the pawn on B2 but
white doesn't need to bother with it you
can simply take the open C line for your
Rook always place your Rook on open
files and now we see why that B2 Pawn
cannot be picked up and the power of
that age Pawn on the other side of the
board you deliver a Checkmate on the
back rank yeah really nasty stuff the
tactics will continue I mean this type
of thing is something that Hikaru have
to worry about for the rest of the game
let's go back to him he's down to two
minutes now it's a five minute
difference between the two players and
looking Grim is he in big trouble uh big
is an understatement I think he's in
huge trouble because remember against
Magnus Carlson in the winners final game
one Magnus won a pawn and had a great
chance at the end game but he didn't
have enough time and the car put
pressure on magnus's clock here Magnus
ahead on the clock he's up a pawn his
King is safer I just feel like
everything going right for Magnus
Carlson he is surely going to take this
game one if he doesn't he is going to be
absolutely devastated yeah and uh Hikaru
against anyone else in the world he
would feel confident about his defensive
chances but here clearly the reason he's
burning time on the clock is because he
hates his position and not only are you
a pawn down also check mating ideas
against your king it's uh yeah multiple
reasons and the clock is now down to
almost just a minute net and Magnus has
got over seven minutes that's a huge
time advantage in a super difficult
situation we've often spoken about how
one of the biggest strands of Hikaru is
his resilience his resourcefulness and
he needs to show that now more than ever
I just don't know what to do because we
keep talking about this white Pawn on H6
which is threatening are we talking with
a queen lands up in the attack then
White Knight can also help out and go
for the attack we were recording Taylor
Swift yesterday I mean white horses
right land me a white horse on F6 that's
bad news for the black king So Hikaru
lashes out with his Pawn push to A5 look
at how quickly though Magnus is
responding and the car needs to have his
moves ready quickly because he's down
under a minute on the clock and he
remains a pawn down on the board amazing
speed that by Magnus it just feels like
he's playing on all sides of the board
and now that Knight can jump up to G5
also opening up the F line for the queen
to land on to try and put pressure on
the white side he's playing on all sides
of the board Magnus has got this Rook on
B5 which takes control of the queen side
any activity against the B Pawn while
the other rook and the queen and the
Knight the arrows that you're drawing
David exactly point out to the idea that
Queen from F3 will threaten that pawn
also threatened to jump onto F6 and that
mate that we've been talking about on
the G7 Square big trouble here for black
I said it so many times once the
opponent's Queen is this far distanced
from her own King you need to go in the
attack you need to Target that enemy
King while you have the opportunity here
it takes Black's Queen three or four
moves minimum to get back to any
potentially defensive square and this
looks like a devastating move Tanya the
one you're mentioning bringing the
Knight forward and uh Magnus I think
will go for that I could also Imagine a
very Magnus type of move would be to
just Shuffle the king towards the corner
towards safety just to avoid any
potential checks Long Term Black's Queen
could come back and annoy the King on
this diagonal at some point so uh just
prophylaxis as we say just get the king
to safety and the Tactics still working
in White's favor but yeah no matter what
no matter what move he chooses right now
looking very promising for white a good
moment I feel for Magnus to stop and
invest some time uh still five minutes
up on the clock with a very very strong
position remember this is best out of
four rapid games and if Magnus wins then
Grand final match he will be the winner
of the air things monsters Hikaru
nagamura he has to win this match to get
a second chance and take it to a grand
final reset and we are enjoying uh you
guys watching this together with us look
at that Colin he's actually watching
this in class naughty before we like it
he's doing all the right things Kaya
calculus ugh
I like calculus was that your favorite
subject no but I liked it I mean call me
a nerd I'm a chess Grandmasters I can't
really hide it but a calculus was fun so
some people need calculus it's a good
subject
any day of the week Caillou is saying
how Hikaru needs to win the match right
now he's thinking about how on Earth
does he save this position and the more
I look at it
the more hopeless it feels David and
we've been discussing all these mating
ideas and Magnus steps up with this
queen to the center of the board
I get the feeling that because of the
mating Nets that we've been showing the
king the black king just caged up on the
king side Hikaru might not have any
better choice than to offer a queen
trade but the end game is no better for
him and uh you predicted it correctly
Tanya and you're right it's no better
for him still just insurmountable
problems it feels like with the black
king on the back rank maybe if the black
king was closer to the center again an
active King in the end game uh he would
have some chances but this one I already
see some trouble there's some variations
here which I think will land on the
board Magnus is happy to just trade one
set of Rooks because that black Rook is
stuck it has to defend passively the
back Rank and now Magnus will start
getting his pieces into the game
starting I think with Rook lift Casey
Bell in the twitch chat saying Magnus
has a bunch of winning moves is that the
case basically yeah it's hard to go
wrong for Magnus because black is
completely tied down they Rook for black
will likely slide next to the king and
just going back to the castle position
to defend this tender F7 Pawn because
White's forces are just jumping forward
and going to go for the the attack so
Magus knows he's winning hikar also
understands that Magnus should be
winning so for akaru it's about just
trying to create some sort of challenges
and that's what he's doing he's going
for the queen side pawns uh B2 is going
to be lost and it's not about Pawn
quantity I mean that's not the only
thing that matters the piece quality is
the more important element of this
position that's why a car didn't even
take the pawn he understood that his
Knight would have actually been trapped
on B2 you see the Knight has nowhere
back to go The Rook has to stay in the
last rank otherwise there's a Checkmate
that gives white a free hand on the king
side or in the center of the board just
to trap that Knight and go ahead and win
at least a pawn and maybe more yeah and
now again Magnus has that luxury of the
move okay he brings his Rook to the
seventh rank as Robert points out this
Pawn is the first Target it's gonna be
the first one that drops at some point
Magnus will happily just activate his
King the Knight will always be trapped
if it ever gets greedy and wow Hikaru
decides to go for it I think there were
no better options this night now stuck
in no man's land and even if you don't
trap it just go on the attack there we
go Magnus Carlson tying down look how
passive these pieces are now he can
reroute his Knight into this juicy F6
square and the king is going to be stuck
in the corner as it bystander for the
rest of the game looking winning now for
white despite the fact it is level
material
and uh yeah Magnus how
smoothly is he going to try and convert
this one he's still got some threats
that he needs to take care of Hikaru
does have some tricks up his sleeve we
see the position that we have as you
were analyzing you called it out David
he's moved the Rook back it looks really
passive but he has a trick of jumping
back with the Knight and you bring it
back into the game you hit both pawns
the A3 pawn and the Central Pawn all
these activity these mating ideas that
we're discussing for Magnus right now
really rely on that E5 Pawn which is why
we see magnus's last move he comes back
with the Rook to take away that key
Square for the night and Hikaru is
Shifting back to the open file again
threatening the knight jump from B2 to
C4 okay some tricks at least some hope
of Salvation if you get your knight back
into the game I'm wondering now how
Magnus proceeds uh your right handy
actually not as easy as it looks at
first glance
still feels like it must be winning
somehow but some work to be done yeah I
feel like if the a pawns are traded that
may allow hikar to breathe a slight sigh
of relief but the problem is that black
will still be passively tied down to the
defense and at some point white will be
able to crash through with Pawn pushes
on the king side so if the g-pawn goes
up and the F Pawn goes up two squares
with a rook on the seventh rank there
will be Devastation for the black king
so it's not ideal to trade off the a
Pawns of course Max wanted to win the A4
Pawn for free and he may be able to do
just that but even if those pawns are
traded I still think he has great
winning chances because black can hardly
move yep he's so slippery Hikaru I've
seen him defend some so many bad
positions over the course of his career
it's probably what he's best at as he
mentioned yesterday in the interview
himself but uh here Magnus it's gonna
feel like a huge missed opportunity if
he doesn't convert it and now suddenly
only one minute difference suddenly
things not so easy Magnus may be
doubting himself for the first time this
game Hikaru doing a great job of
Defending to praise His defensive skills
yes the evaluation Bar says it's dead
lost but he's causing some practical
problems he's not making it
straightforward the winning moves are
likely less obvious now for a human
a hundred percent hikaru's resilience is
from Another Universe is what it feels
like and Magnus is thinking more and
more he's got about a minute on his
clock Hikaru 30 seconds this is not
going to be as easy as we thought by the
way yeah I mean look at her car's face
he is determined and I believe the moves
are going to happen fast because uh this
Pawn on F7 is what magnets will have to
go for and Hikaru let's see Rook F4 here
come the moves here they are all going
and the white king goes up well look at
hikargo he's just chasing the King
around trying to force it to a
sub-optimal square but the F7 Pawn at
the end of the day that Still Remains a
Target and a car down just 11 seconds
when only three seconds increment
remember it's getting dramatic already
in game one it's getting very dramatic
and it feels like magnus's winning plan
here is to just dodge the checks at any
cost maybe drop your king back to D2
kick that black Rook away prevent the
checks yes you allow black to gobble up
your queen side but you're going for the
black king just tunnel vision is all
that's required right now go for that
black king and it should be the end and
he going for it it kind of drops back
very clever defensive move yet again
what a champion he is holding on here
for dear life holistic in the twitch
chat saying Psyduck versus hikachu
I love it
that is amazing and okay shifting Focus
now White's threatening to deliver a
nasty check a mating threat there on the
back rank which Hikaru blocks yet again
it feels like Magnus is throwing
everything at Hikaru but Hikaru is
always swatting it away he always has an
answer and suddenly the Black Knight is
threatening to porn simultaneously
Magnus takes one but okay it does feel
like Hikaru is slightly closer to saving
this game now especially if he can go
and capture that white H Pawn that thorn
in his side and it's heading that that's
exactly what he does he moves that
Knight attacking that H Pawn but you can
pick up the F7 Pawn currently because if
you pick it up with the Knight then you
don't win that 8-6 pawn so white does
have that option Magnus goes for it
picking up a pawn defending his own and
I'm expecting a guy to move the Rook
along the f file and what what happened
no this game is still going yeah he saw
enough time but barely enough time and
that's the problem is the Knight is
kicked out so the White Knight defends
the pawn the Black Knight can't stay
there forever and don't forget that
white has this past Pawn on the queen
side that A3 Pawn still exists you're
gonna start pushing that one up the
board and threatening the black king
with checkmating ideas Hikaru looks very
unhappy with his position shaking his
head there he looked ready to resign he
nearly got out of his chair a moment ago
now Magnus has to be slightly careful
where he puts the king you don't want to
put the King on a passive Square there
we go out into the open out towards
safety and I think uh Hikaru body
language he's ready to resign the white
King's just going to attack these pieces
and now the black king is the one that
is doomed Checkmate is coming Black's
King all alone and Hikaru does
eventually throw in the towel wow Magnus
crossing the strikes first in the Grand
Final he takes the lead winning game one
with the white pieces that means sikara
Nakamura will have to make a comeback at
some point and take this to a grand
final minus looking over this is no
smile on his face
but a good game by the world number one
who takes the lead with the white pieces
they now have five minutes before game
two where Hikaru will have the white
pieces what do you think about magnus's
player Robert I'm not surprised because
in the first match between these two
even though they were drawing all their
games Magnus did have the upper hand he
had winning Advantage he called some of
his mistakes or his misses inexcusable
so Magnus is just playing the same chess
he did uh the other day but he's a
little bit more accurate this time
around he earned that full point take us
through this win for Magnus David yeah
and I just want to show you how Magnus
clinched it in the end and why Hikaru
resigned and why he was so annoyed at
himself because he actually fought back
into this game very well Hikaru defended
against all the threats fought off the
strongest parts of the attack and just
when it looked like he'd survived the
worst he let it slip again mostly
influenced by the clock and here I think
if Hikaru had more time he would have
played a defensive move sliding The Rook
back where it had just come from holding
on to this key F7 Square next move the
Black Knight is threatening to come and
take take this Thornton inside this
really annoying white Pawn instead
however Hikaru panicked and we saw him
laugh on the camera he moved his Knight
to G4 perhaps forgetting that this Pawn
could simply be captured by the White
Knight defending this vital pawn and he
tried to create some counter play here
Hikaru who tried to annoy the white King
by giving some checks but the white king
simply stepped up the board and here in
this position we saw Hikaru resign he
gave a check didn't even wait for Magnus
Carlson's reply because the white king
would step up the board any safe square
and Checkmate is coming the black king
all alone is not going to be able to
defend and Hikaru unfortunately lost
that one but he's he now needs to fight
back he's still got white in the next
game
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
and you can win an air things device
today remember our viewer competition
tweet your answer using the hashtag
chess Champs the question is what do you
think will be the winning bid in a
potential Armageddon and remember you
can also today get a hundred dollars off
an air things device using the QR code
on the bottom of the screen we're gonna
take a quick twitch break and for
everyone else who are subscribers we're
gonna re reveal the puzzle of today
foreign
[Music]
final going on today in division two
Fabiano caruana against you young Yi
what's happening okay I see a point this
just happened a second ago I mean
Fabiano is playing Practically Perfect I
have to say and it was a great
positional masterclass from him with the
white pieces so now the ball is in you
young East Court so like Magnus Carlsen
Fabiano Carona has taken the lead Ivanka
puzzles we love them and today you told
me you have one of your favorite puzzles
with you for the viewers yeah I mean
this is a study by Yuri
dorogov I'll get the name right and it's
actually my favorite study ever wow I
love it and to here you see it on the
board it is white to play and win and uh
a lot of pieces a lot of pieces a lot of
possibilities but the final solution is
so perfect it's just beautiful and it's
pretty forcing so you're looking at all
those checks captures threats and when
you see the solution again share that
answer with your friends just share it
with everyone you know because this is
remarkable and it's such a fun thing to
do on a Friday right gather your friends
family and solve this cool puzzle no no
hints from you yet no I'm not going to
give any hints okay because it's I feel
that this puzzle is so good you actually
need to work it out for yourself and
remember why to play and win and enjoy
solving
enjoy solving and I sneak back into the
studio where we looked at the great
puzzle because game two is about to
start between Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus
Carlsen Hikaru now with the white pieces
he will have to make a comeback at some
point after losing the first one so what
should we expect from Hikaru in game two
top yeah that's a big blow what just
happened in game one and we're talking
about what Magnus did right but I think
that was more about what Hikaru did on
the board with the black pieces of
course he had to have the approach of
trying to again just make the most of
each and every game but he just took so
much risk and now he's a game down with
the white pieces no draw on this one if
Hikaru doesn't win the match is over yes
there's still a mathematical chance for
it but it will be way too difficult Kaya
it all comes down to this game too
Hikaru has to win yeah izikaru usually
mentally strong in situations like this
when he has to make a comeback when he's
home in the first game yeah he's fully
capable of bouncing back in fact what
qualified to him for the candidates is
he lost an early game in one of the
Grand Prix tournaments to Levon aronian
then he went on a winning streak and was
able to secure his place in the
candidates tournament that decided who
would play for the world championship
title so Hikaru can do it but the
problem is he hasn't really played a
game with the white pieces every time he
gets white it seems like he forces a
quick draw so what he has in store is a
big question mark for me but that's the
thing he cannot do that now he will have
to win a game now David yeah he'll have
to win and most likely with whites
Magnus very loses when he has white so
Hikaru in game three if he doesn't win
this one will be suffering but uh yeah
it does feel like because Tanya said
this game is key he needs to get that
self-belief he needs to remind himself
that he can take down Magnus Carson he's
certainly capable but uh can he do it
now he needs to play quicker that's my
main advice to him that last game he was
too slow and the clock cost him even
though he was suffering in the position
he held it together but the clock was
the deciding factor
and Magnus Carlsen with the black pieces
what should we expect from him in this
game now he only needs those draws and
he will be the winner of the tournament
his only loss here was with the white
pieces to argentera gaisy so nobody has
beaten Magnus when he said black he's
been Ultra solid I think we'll see more
of the same he needs to force that car
to beat him he does not want to beat
himself
the second game coming up very shortly
Hikaru with the white piece
five minutes what do you expect they do
in between these games start now
I I think for Hikaru it's just trying to
forget what's happened we didn't really
see him hang around he just left
immediately after losing that game uh
just sort of calming yourself down and
up talking yourself Magnus we saw him in
his seat probably just checking going
over what he's expecting from Hikaru one
thing's for sure
he can't do what he did in their last
match up two days ago Hikaru had this
martial position where he could have
taken his chances continued playing but
instead just repeated moves if he gets
an opportunity like that he can't afford
to do that and that's why we don't see a
1e4 so no Berlin draws no martial
opportunities for Magnus and Hikaru
here's thoughts well with a close
strategic opening which just means we're
gonna get a game no big theoretical
battles yep I love it and the chess Gods
we know they hate players who take draw
quick draws with white especially so I'm
really glad to see Hikaru go for it in
this game playing the reti one of my my
favorite openings so flexible all the
pieces on the board for a long time
quite likely and uh Magnus now looking
off to the side snacking up the other
day he said he loves to snack during the
games between the games and uh now just
choosing what do you think he's eating
right now uh maybe some nuts I'm not
sure uh something uh good for the brain
yeah something nutritious last season on
the tour we saw him eat noodles all the
time I remember that noodle
yes this opening the funny thing about
it Kaya though is that you know we're
happy that we have it ready but it's
also one of magnus's preferred choices
with the white pieces we very often see
Magnus go for this Robert what do you
think about that Hikaru choosing a line
that Magnus himself plays so many times
I think you have no choice because these
top players play Everything Under the
Sun and Magnus does love this as an
opening weapon from the white side but
it's a good choice because you don't
bring the battle immediately and that
can leave some long-term winning chances
I do think that Hikaru needs to press in
this game he can't just rely on the draw
here and hope that he'll survive because
he still will need a victory over Magnus
Carlsen so what are the ideas in this
position you've had no Pawn tension no
trades just yet at some point you are
going to strike in the center and create
some opportunities to trade off pieces
whether it's the C Pawn or the e-pawn so
Hikaru has a wealth of experience
himself he's just trying to figure out
what direction he wants his game to go
and I think he can push his C pawn and
make it an English type of position I
think that means it's a lesson balance
it's not going to be symmetrical and I
think that's exactly what hikar has to
aim for yeah the only
possible problem that I foresee with
this one Robert is that the Queens might
come off uh okay he has gone for this
and I'm expecting Magnus to take this
pawn and now if Magnus is happy with the
draw then he would be uh quite likely to
head into the end game Magnus is very
principled he won't necessarily go for
the most solid approach he'll go for an
approach that he enjoys playing this is
not necessarily A draw of course once
the coins disappear still plenty of
pieces left on the bud plenty of life
left but uh as far as I know this one
has a decent reputation for black black
is very solid you can bring the Knight
out bring the bishop out sometimes you
can push forward this Pawn I'm not sure
whether this is exactly that type of
position to gain a bit more space but
either way Magnus will be looking for a
safe approach another one would simply
be to develop the Knight defend this
pawn and play almost a sicilian but just
with reverse colors Magnus looking away
now deciding what movie he prefers in
this position well according to the math
situation it would make so much sense to
trade it off and pick up the queens and
he goes for an end game perhaps if it
was slightly different on the scoreboard
we would have seen that night developing
move that you were talking about and
after deciding to trade we see a few
moves being blitzed off with Magnus now
making an aggressive Pawn push in the
center asking white the question where
is your knight headed because David
watch out if you take it to the absolute
rim of the board if you make if you take
it to H4 there's always a chance of it
getting trapped eight six first defend
that square and then G5 ideas and then
suddenly you don't have a good Square
for the night of course uh you have to
watch out because the E4 Pawn's hanging
but you don't want to put your knight on
H4 so perhaps Hikaru has to retreat the
Knight all the way back yeah and that
wouldn't be uh something he enjoys doing
either retreating the night it does take
a while for this night to get back on a
better circuit and uh Hikaru I'm
surprised he played this variation
without having a answer prepared right
now I've got to say it feels like he's
freestyling and freestyling against
Magnus come back fire uh so yeah either
this move or maybe bringing it forward
I'm expecting one of those two and the
game will go on Magnus most likely after
one of these moves is going to back up
his Pawn Center Connect Four right now
with these uh with this nice Pawn chain
and uh yeah still some chances Magnus
looks like he's loving like those
smiling to himself
yeah that's he's looking quite amused
and happy with what's happening I wonder
what's going on there
happy with life yeah happy yeah with
something clearly
they're in Canada I have no idea but of
course he's happy about the match result
thus far he's up a full point and with
black he seems to have no problems out
of the opening there's a car Nakamura on
the clock or David was just mentioning
we could see a Connect Four of those
pawns and hikar actually brings his
Knight all the way back so Magnus has
had no struggles against a car over the
board he's maybe had a worse position
for two moves total in all the games
they played here in the air things
master so why not smile he should be
happy you know what I think he's
laughing at what I bet it is because we
know Magnus has a strange sense of music
style he loves those 90s Classics I bet
the chess bras has put something on the
stereo in that house maybe a song or
something like that from the 90s we need
our viewers to send in what they think
has happened yeah what song is Magnus
listening to what's made him laugh it's
made him chuckle
of a mystery but uh you know he's got a
interesting sense of humor as well so it
could be anything knowing Magnus
huh he's laughing he's in a good mood no
doubt uh Magnus Carlsen he's in the lead
in The Grand Final here against Hikaru
Nakamura
and uh Hikaru is fighting to make a
comeback winning this game
to me it just feels like the kind of
opposite of the position you want in a
almost must win situation now suddenly
if you look at the white Knights one of
them is stuck on the bottom of the board
one is that one of them is stuck on the
side of the board Magnus has this
perfect Pawn structure he can't control
himself distracted he's just he's
finding something so amusing right now
and I have no idea what's so funny I
mean I get it he's really happy with the
position he's got he can't stop laughing
do you think Hikaru has magnus's camera
up on the screen I hope not that is the
last thing you want to see after losing
a game and almost having to win on
demand this one yeah and uh Magnus after
I think a battle with himself there
finally fighting off the smile and uh
yeah wow I don't know what's happened
it's a big mystery and David he needed
to do that he needed to get a grip
because Hikaru did have a huge threat in
that position when he developed that
night he wanted to actually step even
further on the board with that Knight on
the queen side and we see magnus's last
move stops any further night jump so
just making sure that Knight stays there
uh while Hikaru doing exactly what he
did in game one with the white pieces
playing on the queen side here he moves
away from the long diagonal notice that
Bishop on G7 targeting that pawn on B2
which really stopped White's development
and flow in the way pieces would have
come out and now I'm expecting him to go
one step ahead with that pawn in front
of the Rook to defend the C4 Pawn Robert
I know that Hikaru Nakamura is the
Fisher random Champion but it feels that
he's playing Fisher random while Magnus
is just playing regular chess I mean all
of White's pieces are scrambled of
across the board here blacks pieces on
very good squares harmonious we have the
pawn chain from H7 all the way down to
E4 in the center which blunts that
pancetto Bishop in front of the white
king and look at Black's fan keto Bishop
on G7 it stares across the entire
diagonal everything going right for
Magnus Carlson in this game I don't know
what he was laughing about but he does
have good reason to be happy he has
nothing wrong in his position everything
every piece on a good Square yep I agree
it looks like Fisher random gone wrong
for Hikaru but he is at least trying to
break that chain uh break down that
black pawn chain in the center and
starts with the head and that E4 Pawn if
you can get rid of that suddenly the
white pieces have much more freedom much
more life and uh I think Magnus here
would be very reluctant to trade off the
pawn that has just moved on F3 uh he'll
be looking for clever ways to do that if
that work clever more clever ways wiser
ways more practical ways and he brings
this night out again look at Black's
pieces perfect centralization the two
Black Knights on the Square that we tell
all beginners to develop them to just uh
controlling everything two black bishops
very well poised for the position to
become open and white stragglers there
especially those two knights I don't
like the look of them at all Hikaru is
so good at rotating his Knights but uh
he'll fight he'll find it very difficult
to get them to more active posts at
least in the next few turns while Magnus
finally deals with this King brings the
black Rooks to the center no problems at
all for black it's definitely white
who's trying to equalize in this game
but that shouldn't be enough for Hikaru
not a good start to this one not a good
start at all you've got the white pieces
you want those Queens on the board you
want to have a dynamic position but
instead here you are on the back foot in
an end game and you can just
aesthetically see and tell that White's
position lacks so much space black has
advanced those spawns the pieces are out
now looking at connecting the Rooks for
Magnus the pleasure seems very easy I'm
trying to figure out what it is that
Hikaru can play for in this position and
the one thing that that comes to mind is
this Connect Four that you're talking
about David with the Pawns in the center
they have created some dark squared
weaknesses so perhaps Hikaru can look at
developing his own Bishop to a good
active Square because with the spawn
Advance the F4 square has been weakened
the bishop can land there eyeing another
weakness in Black scam well I wouldn't
call it a weakness but at least upon
that is under attack Hikaru is dreaming
right now and hoping that Magnus trades
those Central pawns because if he does
that then the Knight can jump back into
the game the Knight hops from E1 to F3
comes to the center of the board and
you're suddenly the bishop on G2 becomes
active and this is the dream position
but Magnus is never never going to trade
these pawns yeah he'll force uh Hikari
to contort himself and waste several
Tempe before ever allowing a trade-in
remember we've talked about this in the
first game it's about allowing a trade
on your own terms Magnus with his last
move said yes you can take this Pawn
yourself but I will simply recapture I'm
not even sure which way Magnus back you
could take with the pawn still blunting
this bishop still caging controlling
this Knight or you could take back with
your own Knight opening up this
beautiful Bishop on the long diagonal
and saying to Black okay this is a nice
Outpost uh sorry saying to White this is
a nice Outpost and you can only
eliminate this Knight at the cost of
your fiancato bishop and uh okay Hikaru
pushes his Pawn forward one square to B3
I don't like it yes it's connect three
this time but uh far less effective than
Black's Pawn chain and still some dark
square holes on the side of the board
but he needs to do that also David to
free up his own Knight because he had to
defend that C4 Pawn the tip of that pawn
chain that you were pointing at so that
the Knight can reroute itself from C2 to
hopefully the center of the board and
also control that Central D4 Square so
it's not a happy move but a move that
had to be made at some point to free up
the pieces and I think the reason that
Magnus Carlson is sitting and thinking
right now is his King he can Castle
kingside you can't go Queen so you're
not allow the castle through check and
he does not Castle he brings his King up
to F7 so he says this is a position
there are a lot of pieces the queenless
middle game let's call it that but my
king can be safe in 7 F7 and it's closer
to the center in the event I trade off
the Rooks yeah really nice safe Square
for the king and uh there's no chance
it's going to come under fire anytime in
the next few moves simply as Robert says
Shifting The Rook to the center once you
contest for the d-file the the open file
on the board then all of your pieces are
at play and no danger at all I'm still
expecting one of tania's ideas there
either first attacking this loose Pawn
the only weak spot in the black Camp the
Achilles heel there or to relocate the
White Knight white is solid we should
mention so although we're kind of waxing
a lyrical about Black's chances uh
Hikaru still isn't out of it yet in this
game at least not in terms of losing but
he brings his Bishop to the side and
Magnus finally does try to fight for
this file
um I'm gonna
stick my neck out here and predict a
draw just because it feels like Magnus
doesn't need to go all out in this game
but also it feels like black is never
really in trouble but didn't mind is
also not castle in the last game so two
games in a row sure how rare is that
well when you get to 2800 plus you can
break all the rules if you're watching
this home please cast your king listen
to your coaches get that King safe but
magnus's King has never been in any
danger it wasn't about as king just
darting to the side of the board and
just being secured by the other pieces
he's using his other pieces with great
effect and in this position without
Queens his King is safe and sound
and in both these games we did have a
queen trade out of the opening so very
often we're told that in end games the
King has to be used as a piece and
that's what Magnus has done in this one
as well as get keeping it centralized
keeping it close to all his forces it is
the best Square for the king you have to
connect the Rooks and the idea we were
discussing David is on the board Hikaru
tries to reroute the Knight to a better
Square in the process also controls
takes hold of those very important dark
squares on in the center of the board
but it still feels as a white is so
passive right now yeah well it's
extremely passive even if you get uh
kind of give Hikaru two moves here I
don't think he can really make Headway
into the black position I simply don't
know what he's trying to do next other
than exchange pieces yes you can maybe
lessen the pressure because you are so
cramped by trading off a set of Rooks
maybe even trading off a set of nights
if you're given the time but
is that fighting for an advantage with
white it doesn't feel that way there
might be one idea here is that tension
from the F3 Pawn to the E4 Pawn uh right
right now black has two Defenders the
pawn on F5 and the Knight behind it on
F6 they're both protecting that pawn but
if white says you can have the bishop
pair I will take the material and use
the bishop on B2 and takes that Knight
on F6 then all of a sudden white may go
up a pawn and say where is your
compensation maybe you objectively are
better but you're gonna have to prove it
not so easy in a position with limited
material yeah so maybe a threat on the
board uh that Robert after Bishop takes
bishop and capturing a pawn I must admit
I wasn't even thinking of being greedy
here I'm so attached to my Bishops I
have these blind spots that I forget
sometimes but you're right that was a
threat and therefore Magnus not wanting
to allow that to happen he finally did
trade but now at least after the White
Knight gets free again a possible threat
for Hikaru suddenly his position looks
far more harmonious far better and maybe
Magnus will have to take a time out just
to block this check just to cover this
square and okay finally it does feel
like Hikaru has got over his opening
problems here and should be able to
equalize I don't think more than that
but at least he'll be happier than he
was and he's thinking in this position
is he really contemplating taking in any
other way I guess you could take with
the pawn just to keep the pawn structure
a kind of almost symmetrical to try and
push this Pawn forward next but it does
feel very slow I guess the idea here
would be to bring the Knight this
direction so um possible plus sides for
that move too but Hikaru needs to play a
bit quicker he needs to at least have a
Time Advantage if he wants to win this
game
it is a big question here for white what
you recapture with and I think Hikaru
has made well the more human approach
here and what seems to me the right
choice to bring your pieces out to try
to play for peace activity here and he
is he has a huge threat on the board we
were talking about how black needs to
stop this but this is the best position
that Hikaru has had all game today maybe
all day today actually and we can expect
some more trades of the pieces again
trying to open up that Bishop on G2 that
is the key piece in White's position the
king side Bishop the light squared
Bishop right now stopped right now
there's a block on the road on that
diagonal with black snide on C6 I'm also
expecting a trade of these two nights
the White Knight on the queen side and
the Black Knight on the queen side to
open up the chances for this fan chatter
Bishop so there are some technicalities
still to be solved for black hair
what do you think we've talked about
what Hikaru needs is Magnus gonna be
happy to just shut this one down move on
to the next game
yeah there's no doubt on my mind that if
you can just Swap all the pieces and
make a draw he'll do that because with
the white pieces in game one in the
winners Final in game one here in the
Grand Final Magnus has had an advantage
with white he could not convert in the
winners final hikara played great
defense and used Max's clock against him
but today that was a really good display
of just complete control over the board
so we see speaking of control the board
Magnus pushing his Rook Pawn up taking
away White's lone threat in the position
and if the status quo remains White's
Pawn structure is worse than blacks you
have an isolated Pawn on E2 black has
two Pawn Islands white has three so we
have connected pawns for black and that
one Pawn on E2 that's not a happy piece
and if black can attack it it's going to
be difficult to defend yeah and uh
Magnus okay now not smiling now frowning
slightly for the first time in the game
not looking too happy momentum wise it
is slightly in White's favorite I feel
this position is utterly balanced it's
very equal chances for both sides but uh
yeah he definitely will feel like he had
control and he's lost a bit of control
now it's Hikaru with a free move to try
and create some threats maybe Tanya will
be right and we'll see one of the
knights jump forward just to trade-off
open up the two white Bishops which are
very well placed on those two longest
diagonals I mean well the air quality is
much better in magnus's uh than it was
at the beginning of the day interesting
I wonder if in the break time maybe you
went to open a window but it served him
well in game one he played very very
convincingly there and uh okay Hikaru
again needs to speed up he needs to make
a decision well if white doesn't trade
off one of the knights what Magnus wants
to do in this position is actually jump
with his own Knight forward at the
center of the board and try and trade
off these dark squared Bishops and there
we have it do we have a move Hikaru has
decided to jump in with the Knight it's
so important for him to get the activity
of the light squared Bishop because the
only Target in the position for white
hair are blacks Queen side bonds that
born on B7 notice that if black does
trade on D4 pick up that night white can
jump in pick it up with his own Knight
hit that Bishop on E6 also Target that
pawn on B7 so we see Hikaru here trying
to create some chances in a position
that currently looks like it doesn't
have that much poison that much venom in
it but one gets the feeling that Magnus
still needs to be a little careful here
yeah he definitely needs to be a little
careful here
um there are dual threats as you
mentioned Tanya this one and this one
you can solve them both with uh one move
just retreating the bishop but again it
feels like a step in the wrong direction
the bishop is very very passive here you
do hold everything together I do wonder
if hikaru's plots his plan here is after
Knight takes Knight to actually capture
another way or potentially even flicking
a check I haven't worked out the
consequences here but uh you could at
least think of flicking in a check the
king moves again where does it go uh
this is a track hitting this pawn and uh
for example if we drop back to its start
Square now Hikaru could capture this
Knight with his Rook or with his bishop
and still
something to worry about at least for
Magnus Carlson this Pawn is loose and
this Pawn is loose so both flanks both
sides of the board you have issues and
if this isn't if this is a potential
Hazard for Magnus then he has to go into
the tank now as he's doing because white
is adding up the threats stepping up the
pressure I think he's wisely spending
time as you're saying because it could
be dangerous territory for him and that
part every pod purse creates a weakness
in your position and here is the G6 Pawn
lost its friend defending it so 95 check
will be a big threat in a variety of
positions I do think that White's
position is a little bit too loose if we
just uh kind of even look at this line
just two steps further once the king
slid back to the square you put it on
and we see a swap of Rooks on the D4
square that Bishop on D4 is loose and is
a bishop on G7 so the Knight on F6 moves
out the way either to G4 or back to D7
and we see that this bishop on D4 is
hanging the 9 E5 under attack twice
Magnus can work his way out of this so
he has everything under control for now
and while he does he does pick up
tonight so this gives white the
opportunity to go for this line the
Intermezzo that we're talking about and
I often feel that inter measures are the
easiest moves to miss of course Hikaru
hasn't missed the check here but in
general in chess we're so tempted
towards recapturing immediately but
Hikaru of course has found that he knows
that he needs to go in for this attack
and I really like this line David that
you were pointing out hitting that pawn
on G6 hitting that pawn on B7 and simply
capturing recapturing the central Knight
with the bishop nice play Here by Hikaru
out of an opening that I don't think he
was super happy about I don't think he
was ecstatic about the position that he
got that he's managed to create some
chances and intramesso what's that mean
we need to translate there's various
different words different terms I guess
in English we would say like an
intermediate move so before playing
automatic recapture we flick in another
move first normally it's a check to gain
some time and only then do we capture so
for example in that last position white
gave up a night temporarily and flicked
in a check first black reacts and now
he'll regain the material balance and
that black knight in the center of the
board will be taken will be captured
there's various terms into mezzo I guess
it's Italian and it's related music uh
related to music there's also the German
word zwift like uh literally between
move and uh yeah it's basically a
shocker yeah
but you get something else yeah it's uh
normally something you don't want to see
if you're on the wrong end of an
Intermezzo but uh here Magnus reacted
very quickly did bring his King back to
a Central Square and Robert predicted
this whole line predicted the future uh
thanks to the looseness of White's
pieces black can solve his problems
tactically that's often what you need to
do and I think Magnus is okay and
because oops sorry go ahead yeah because
I was uh there was just uh such a good
pass saying yeah Robert predicted the
future and the question is has that
Robert predicted the future if we have
Armageddon we have asked the expert to
place their bed in this envelope for
what they think get the winning bid for
time will be if we do see Arma get on
today I have all their predictions in
this envelope and we're also asking you
at home the same question what do you
think the winning bid for time will be
in Armageddon you can tweet your answer
using hashtag chess Champs and one lucky
winner will get an air things device
signed by Magnus Carlsen himself I think
right now Hikaru is streaming and hoping
to get that Armageddon and after that
first game loss he needs to win one game
in this match to just equalize to just
level the score and get into that
Armageddon but of course that will be a
whole different mind games yeah
different strategies the two have
already played one arm again so they
kind of know how they think Magnus call
it a soul read that one second win that
he had
no Tanya I thought you were going to say
he's dreaming of winning this air things
device what happens actually if Hikaru
writes in himself Tweets in the exact
time he's gonna bid ah he'll be the
closest one oh that's a loophole it's
clearly Paul I bet everything's will be
very happy to send any other things
device to icaro the question is do you
think he would want Inside by Magnus oh
what's happening okay actually nothing
that dramatic but he found a really
clever way to trade Bishops I was
expecting the White Knight to retreat
but you've had a much more active Square
sorry that Kaya it's just a chess
player's kind of uh reaction yeah to a
shocker exactly wow show us why this is
so beautiful
um yeah now it's died down into a very
normal position but uh he just found an
artistic way to do it that one was for
the memes for the fans from Hikaru so we
were looking at this position Robert
predicted it pretty much uh pressure on
this night and along this diagonal the
white Bishop behind it is loose so this
White Knight has to defend its Bishop I
was expecting just a simple drop back
and after a bishop trade we reached this
position which actually occurred in the
game but instead Hikaru played a move
that wasn't on radar I've got to admit
he jumped out the other way and it looks
like the Knight has just sacrificed its
own life it's committed suicide here but
luckily you're attacking this bishop so
there's no no time to take this knight
uh instead we saw a trade and back to
the same position but uh but Hikaru did
it in a more forceful more artistic way
huh that was that was quite a stunner
for a moment and of course it was
White's dream as well to trade off this
fan chartered Bishop he's done it what
black also wants to do is try and pick
up that G2 Bishop the white slight
Square bishop and the Knight I can
imagine it jumping onto E3 hitting that
Rook on D1 hitting that Bishop on G2
let's say white does come up with the
Rook to D3 attacking the Knight black
can swap off this uh monstrous Bishop
that white has and I think that's a
trait that Magnus is happy about the
more pieces that get traded black skin
moves forward we know Magnus loves his
King in the center connect those Rooks
looks like a happy end game for black or
whether he's happy or not he did in fact
do this and this is the variation we
have on the the board and well for
magnets there's no holes in this
position no weaknesses that said a
knight can actually outclass a bishop in
the ending because the Knight can jump
from color complex to color complex it
can go from light Square to dark and
that Bishop has to stay on the light
Square so for now everything under
control for Magnus Carlsen but there
could be a future where the Knight
causes some problems on the dark squares
that that black Bishop cannot handle
yeah maybe at some point trying to jump
into this Central post but that's why
Magnus sorry as Tanya predicted
advancing the black king the black king
is going to be the guardian of the dark
squares while the Bishop tries to get
active on those light squares so he's
called he's controlling all those color
complexes for now but Hikaru will be
trying to make some Headway with his
Knight maybe with his Rook on the open
file still some chances it's still
imbalanced enough to win this one for
both sides but objectively it's very
very level right now both ticking down
to three minutes on the clock what do
you think Robert what will be the result
in this game it's looking to be a likely
draw just because of the limited
material but it depends on hikara's
mindset if he really feels like he must
push and I think we've seen that
throughout the game he's kept more
pieces on the board taking some risk in
the process that if he feels this is now
or never he could in fact lose this game
but I I said and we were talking about
it earlier it feels like our has to win
now that we're here you can't just
sacrifice the match that if he draws
this game and is able to hold with the
black piece in game three he still will
get that rebuttal game four with the
white pieces he doesn't want to
sacrifice the entire match right now in
what looks like an even end game David
when you're playing a game like this how
much of the match situation is sneaking
into your head more than it should yeah
it's so hard to block out what's going
on around you these guys they're very
aware that there's thousands of fans
watching out there cheering for them but
of course they're able to perform under
those incredible that's a kind of
incredible amount of pressure for myself
I struggle especially when I know
there's so much on the line there's a
huge title there's money there's
everything at stake uh yeah I really
have in my past uh in throughout my
career I've kind of struggled to put
that to one side but these guys are good
at that and they will find a way to
focus especially for Hikaru I feel for
Magnus it's maybe easier to drift
because he's a point-up he knows he's
done half of the hard work for Hikaru he
is so focused on the fact he needs to
win so everything else will be blocked
out just uh for this game or two
meanwhile Magnus is throwing a pawn
forward he's opened up his Bishop that
black Bishop is now
like uh like an arrow darting down
towards that white H3 Pawn on the light
Square actually there's multiple tactics
in the position and just to show one
idea off here
um if Hikaru is careless I'm not sure
whether it works to be honest but uh if
Pawn takes porn right now and captures
this Pawn black does have the option of
taking this guy with his Rook luring the
white king out onto a light square a
rook sacrifice but you win back to piece
immediately with a nice skewer the king
moves out the way and we capture this
rook and this is not necessarily winning
for black it's not a winning tactic but
it's just a nice way to keep things
simple and actually a bishop often
outclasses a knight with pawns on both
sides of the board actually today this
morning I was annotating a game by our
friend Simon Williams a ginger GM where
in the play-ins for this tournament he
won a very nice end game with Bishop for
knight uh because there were pawns on
both sides of the board racing and the
bishop with its long range is the
superior piece so a really clever tactic
from Magnus Carlson dual threats now or
triple threats of taking this Pawn
taking this Pawn with this bishop but
also capturing this Pawn with this Rook
how does Hikaru fight against this
things are getting more and more
difficult for Hikaru now this last move
of Magnus some serious questions and
hikari's got about two minutes to answer
the line that you were pointing at makes
one really not want to take on F4 and
create all these weaknesses the weak
Bonds on the king side but the other
option is equally unpleasant if you push
that pawn the Jeep on up to G4 trying to
take away that key F5 Square from the
bishop black can also Advance his own
Jeep on one step ahead and now notice
this F4 Pawn it's such a big strength in
Black's position we call this a
protected past Pawn One of White's
pieces is forever going to be left to
stop the spawn from getting further down
the board and it's a youth strength and
white in in Black's position this is a
nightmare to deal with yeah and he
called me right now just weighing up his
options is he going to capture this
point yes but now his winning chances
will disappear and your moves on the
board David immediate Blow from Magnus
Carlsen he had the time to calculate it
he's a minute up on the clock and here
again Hikaru what do you do you have so
many weaknesses this point under threat
maybe you just take this truck and go
down into the end game where it should
be a draw but you have to be careful
with white yeah he can slide his Rook
over instead of taking the Rook all the
way to the G1 Square attacking G6 but
the black Rook says well I can do the
same slide right back to D6 and this
Pawn structure is better for black we
see that hey car actually decides to
strike with the move Pawn to B4 and I
get the scent that he is playing for a
win now it will likely backfire he's
gonna have a worse position but I can
just take this pawn and B4 and then look
at this it's like bowling when you have
a split all of White's pawns all over
the place Black's pawns are next to each
other much easier to defend whereas
White's pawns are really an ugly sight
to see yeah that's an isil for sure and
Magnus goes for a different option he
actually went for this a pawn
immediately but still the same point
remains these ugly pawns these ugly
pawns Advantage black right now and
throughout the event we've spoken about
just how helpless the knights feel
against a rook past Bond and take a look
at that a pawn that Magnus has currently
one it starts racing down the board
White's night is going to find it so
difficult to defend it Robert you were
talking about a bad oh my God we have a
repetition are we going to get a draw
it's up to Magnus now Hikaru leans back
he was shaking his head there it's at
magnus's disposal if he keeps checking
and it keeps pinning with the black Rook
the white King has to keep running out
of that rook's eye line do you think
he's going to go for it but he knows
he's better here and that's so tempting
to play on because Magnus with his
magnets touch about end games but also
the Mad situation uh David is playing in
his mind he knows if he draws he gets a
white in the next game he gets closer to
that Championship but he can play on
here Magnus I think he's going to play
on did you see hikara as well looked so
unhappy super unhappy for a few moments
there just bombing his head he was like
come on give me the draw give me the
draw let's move on to the next one but
Magnus is teasing him now not making a
decision yet not making a move heck I
was really hoping right that Magnus goes
for it we've got a game on our hands wow
going for the win Magnus Carlsen and
activating the black king oh this one it
looks so good visually for black so I
don't blame him at all Magnus for going
for this but Hikaru needs to recompose
himself now to defend and Magnus
probably estimates his losing chance is
nearing zero so even if he won't win
this game he should not lose but look at
it Carl go he brings his Knight forward
next will be his Rook up in the king's
line Rook B6 check across the sixth rank
that B7 Pawn is a bit tender and watch
out if hikar can push his C5 Pawn those
are double and isolated we're talking
about them being eyesores he can
eliminate his own pawns off for a trade
and then maybe go after this black
Bishop so a good chance for hikar knock
more just to create some chaos but
ultimately Magnus Carlson has everything
under control like usually does
yep and I love this attitude just always
activity over anything that's the motto
of the top chess players in the world
now he's trading off those pawns again
Robert predicting the future and look at
this black Bishop doesn't have too many
safe squares he finds one Magnus and
Hikaru shaking his head yet again surely
that Rook is going to go and grab that
black apron before it starts running
before it starts making a dart towards
promotion and level material two points
against two points don't no winning no
losing chances sorry for Magnus Carson
but can he press it for the win Hikaru
he's just furious at himself but he
needs to knuckle down and at least make
a draw in this one at least make it
close in this match and we're gonna see
we're gonna see him give checks and
Magnus falls back does he have to go for
a repetition now because I don't see
where you're hiding with your king
unless you march all the way to the
queen side
I think Hikaru should be really grateful
that he has a draw here he looks really
devastated but just give the draw move
on to the next one still two games to uh
catch up to get that win this one hasn't
been his best effort but he's done
enough to secure draw a fair result in
the end and I think we're going to see
it Robert
yeah there's no choice I mean what can
white do besides give the checks your
Pawn C4 is loose if you try to play for
when that outside Pawn the black Rook
Pawn will go up the board so we see the
check back and forth the game is a draw
and that's a fair result I think hikara
did not have winning chances throughout
and Magnus Carlson when he had a moment
to try for a win he said I'll try a
little bit but I'm not going to go all
in there's no point
he runs offikaru Nakamura with the white
pieces he did not get the win he needs
in this game Magnus Carlsen is still in
the lead after two out of four games
here in the Grand Final looking over the
position Magnus and uh Hikaru how will
he be feeling right now Tanya
happy I think both games he's the one
the only player who had any chances he's
played the match flawlessly so far
Hikaru of course taking super super
duper risks but they have backfired in
round one in round two with the white
pieces he didn't get anything with white
Hikaru is not happy right now uh the
next game he starts with black if Magnus
wins the next one the tournament is over
Magnus will be the champion Hikaru needs
to make sure with the black pieces he
remains in control don't give Advantage
Magnus out of the opening yeah is there
anything in this game we should look
over David maybe we can just recap
towards the closing stages where Magnus
locked it down and took all risk out of
the position and we mentioned that
Hikaru didn't get off to the best start
but he had been turning the game around
he had now created small imbalances
there's this Knight for Bishop imbalance
and also in terms of the pawn structure
there's four versus three on the queen
side for white so something to cling on
to something to get hopeful about but
Magnus now with these next two classy
moves first throwing a Pawn on the fire
and then Rook takes Pawn he locked it
down he said to Hikaru you're never
winning this game this does rely on a
tactic that King takes Rook is met by
this nasty skewer picking up the white
rope next and the white uh Knight will
struggle to fight against the black
Bishop Hikaru instead trying to go for
it as Robert said trying to create
winning chances still but uh here Magnus
just shut things down by going for the
white pawns and White's Pawn structure
here was too ugly no winning chances a
really nice sequence there just to
simplify the equation and make things
simple for Magnus little less than 10
minutes before game three stars Magnus
Carlsen will have the white pieces if he
wins that game he will be the winner of
the air things Masters and yesterday our
friends at air things and meet up they
organized a watch party at the good
night here in Oslo
[Music]
thank you
and uh air things is what it's all about
in this tournament you can win a sign
air things devised by Magnus Carlson
today we are asking everyone to place
your bet for what the lowest bid will be
in case of Armageddon and you can place
your bet using the hashtag chess Champs
on Twitter one lucky winner will get a
side air things device and remember
today you can get hundred dollars off an
air things device just use your phone
see on this QR code and go grab your air
things device right now we're gonna take
a quick twitch break if you're not a
subscriber but if you are a subscriber
well let's hang out here in the studio
foreign
[Music]
on this very final day of the earth
things Masters Magnus Carlsen still in
the lead in The Grand Final in division
one how about division two Ivanka is
Fabiano still in the lead there yeah
he's still in it but it doesn't look
like
might continue because
it's been a very topsy-turvy game and it
looks like yuyangi is actually going to
take the second game okay
so if we're having some troubles with
your microphone you're like I need to
turn it on and uh so if uh wins the
second game he ties the match he has to
uh win this first match in the Grand
Final to take it to a reset and right
now yes I can see on the bar it's
looking good for you to make that come
back all right yeah we also have the
puzzle today one of your favorite
puzzles of all time let's remind the
viewers what it's all about today yeah
it's such a fantastic puzzle with lots
of uh well one big resource in the
position now it looks like a quite
complicated position after all black
does have two queens but uh take a look
at the black king it's in danger and
that's why it's white play and win and I
have to say when you find the solution
it is so beautiful it's the kind that
you actually just want to share on
social media at your Meetup in the
studio and you just when I go running
and I have to say I was first saw it
like in 2010 and it just captured my
imagination ever since
what is it that you like so much about
it
it's got a such aesthetic value and I
have to admit when I first saw it I
didn't catch who composed it and so I
was haunted by this and I was asking
everyone did you see this puzzle do you
know of a puzzle where it ends like this
and they went nope and then I saw it in
Judith pogo's book and I was like yep
got it all right and uh there we go yep
on the screens behind us we see there is
a result that you yangi has tied the
match incredible stuff so now game three
and four coming up what do you think
what what you expect from the rest of
this match well Fabi does have the white
pieces and he did prove in the first
game but he was very very powerful you
know he came very well prepared and he
just looked like he was in full control
and you Yang Yi when he struck back with
the white pieces I mean again it looked
like the opposite you know like he was
in complete control as well so it's
going to be a very tight battle I think
and uh Fabiano obviously playing from uh
for the us but I hear rumors he's
actually sitting in Spain during the air
things monsters and New York in China
it's super late for him playing this
final yeah but I do say that chess
players are night owls so I hopefully
you know this time isn't actually going
to affect his performance it hasn't so
far you know he's been very impressive
he's a creative player and uh well I
can't wait to see what lies ahead yeah
all right you guys if you followed our
show yesterday you might have heard that
we talked about Harry Potter and wizards
chess and in the first book there is a
scene where uh where there is a game of
Wizard's Chest going on leading into the
Philosopher's Stone most people will not
be able to remember the moves in that
games but this is what happened when
David Howell tested Magnus Carlson's
memory
I'm now going to be showing Magnus some
historical chest positions let's see if
he recognizes them
[Music]
position I bet it looks familiar uh-huh
yeah uh this looks an awful lot like a
tall but Winnick I think the
continuation here was probably Queen D5
and then Rook A6
and uh one yes
[Music]
I was literally reading about this like
this is the book that is on my bedside
table about because power of karpov
matches
[Music]
does this ring any bells
yeah this is the old making one uh that
took a tricky Mist so this is Anan
Evancho from one of the uh Intel rapid
tournaments probably from like 95 or
something 94 I think 94 yeah yeah you're
completely correct
now I'm going to play through an opening
and stop me when you recognize the game
and if you can tell me who was playing
Black in this one okay
[Music]
so I'm sure you've seen this opening
before it's gonna be unknown against
[Music]
okay good one
uh so this is like top three worst chess
memories that I have this is the game
Carlson Howell from World youth
Championship 2002. I needed to win the
last game I was half a point in front
the most annoying part I remember about
that last round is that and the promise
she was playing against
an Indonesian players
I think he played the karukan as black
he had an extra pawn and a great
position and then he just collapsed and
I was losing my advantage as well and I
just remembered raging like crazy uh
obviously it got David uh bronze medal
so that's that's a good part let's go
downhill from there wow 19 years ago and
you still remember the game next to you
[Music]
I mean this could have been some both
game or I played or something
that's a good guess that's a good guess
I'm probably gonna need a hint okay it's
from uh the entertainment industry it's
it's okay so black is down a queen
so from the first Harry Potter movie
they play the Scandinavian and then they
went 93 Queen C6 so is it from from that
one well done okay
needed some serious hints but but it
still could have been anything after the
entertainment industry a good one though
still blows my mind Magnus had no hints
David just put the pieces on the board
what's your reaction what is that brain
how does he do this yeah it is just
something I've never seen before I mean
the guy remembers being 11 what was
happening on the board next to him not
just his games what players have played
the tournament that they played in and
that Harry Potter movie how he said the
Queens are not on the board it was a
Scandinavian yeah how does he do this
I'm just mind blowing I can't believe it
I'm just proud of him he's forgiven
David so that's the biggest
accomplishment of all he started talking
to me like seven years later after that
game
incredible mind on Magnus cross and his
memory is just mind-blowing and he could
be about to win the very first event in
the Champions just for 2023 if he wins
this game he will be the winner of the
year of things monsters Hikaru Nakamura
he cannot lose and he has to win either
this one or the next one to take it to
Armageddon and we have the first move on
the board in game three yeah it's the
Kingsport opening 1e4 and Hikaru is he
just posing it looks like his blue steel
right now like does he know the game has
started uh or is he just genuinely
thinking about his first move he's 100
thinking about the opening approach here
because it's really with the black
pieces under normal situations you'd be
happy to just draw and get up and leave
Hikaru wants to keep the game going he
needs to understand does he rely on that
fourth game only with the white pieces
he'll have one chance and he says no I'm
also going to maximize my chances with
the black pieces doesn't go for a
potential Berlin or a potential a quick
draw with the King pawn moves but starts
with the Sicilian making his intentions
clear in the middle game I want
attacking chess with the black pieces it
cost him almost one minute to play one
move his first move surely he had a 10
minute break he should have been coming
up with an opening strategy we have the
night off I love it maybe maybe unless
Magnus gives a check right now which he
has done in World Championship matches
where he only needs a draw I'm thinking
back to his match against Anna and he
needed a draw with white he locked
things down no open Sicilian I played
that opening my whole life but I think
that what Hikaru Nakamura is trying to
attempt Magnus Carlos and be provocative
say let's play an aggressive game it's a
sicilian you won a class you love chess
just like I do but the match situation
calls for Magnus carlsenal score one
point if he draws the next two games he
is the champion of the air things
Masters Bishop B5 check is ultra solid
he plays it that's what we were
expecting I think that Hikaru knows that
Magnus wants to avoid any of the
Tactical sequences so I think a good
choice from Magnus Carlson I'm sad
I was really hoping for that D4 Central
break give
that of course my Miss goes for the
solid Russell limo opening one that was
made super popular in the 2018 World
Championship match between Magnus and
Fabiano caruana yeah and I haven't seen
Hikaru play this reply to that Bishop
check before I must admit normally he
blocks with a piece in a different way
earlier but now white is the first to
Castle White is already occupying the
center and watch out for Magnus just
drop back his light Square Bishop at
some point and then start pushing pawns
to control some squares Hikaru needs to
get his skates on right now and develop
his pieces his King side pieces there we
go starting with the Knight but uh still
theoretical position of course and it's
just up to uh hikara Now to create some
imbalance if he or create some uh
something at least for Magnus to think
about I'm not that optimistic for black
to be honest here because Magnus he's
the leading expert in these types of
structures this exact opening it's going
to take her a lot to just to surprise
him let alone find something that's
actually objectively uh dangerous or
strong and white can throw the D4 Pawn
right that's always a play in these
Sicilians but instead because of the way
black is developed white can actually
push the C Pawn up one square to C3 to
reinforce the D4 Square you would like
to have multiple Pawns in the center
often in the Sicilian you only get your
e-pawn while the d-pawn gets traded but
here if you start with the move C3 right
now and then play D4 you're going to be
able to recapture with your pawn and
that's the healthy Center you want two
pawns sticking out there taking control
over important squares the Knight on B1
can leap out to the C3 Square as well
that's as healthy as it gets in the
center of the board when you're looking
at an opening yeah meanwhile Magnus
plays this move first putting his Pawn
on H3 just preventing any potential
Bishop pins later on and he'll still go
for this plan I think that Robert was
suggesting that he's just trying to
finesse it a bit first but now Hikaru
what is he gonna go for I have seen
variations for example kicking the
bishop back home first and then getting
really ambitious this isn't this if it
was Simon Williams here in the studio
he'd be like push Gary push Gary push
the gboard try to go for the white king
but I doubt Hikaru is uh gonna employ
that one in this position in this game
video Mike David I mean let's not forget
the math situation and the one thing
that always comes to a chess player's
mind when your opponent makes this move
the pawn push the Rook Pawn to H3 where
you haven't Castle yourself is how you
can break open that g file it's
definitely something that Hikaru is
thinking about right now it's a huge
risk to take he can even move the Rook
one step and prepare that pawn Advance
he could sacrifice it but the ideas
remain the same will he go all out or
all in however you want to call it
because there's no turning back if
Hikaru takes this decision to advance
that g Pawn using that H3 move that
Magnus has made as a hook in the
position to open up the king side and
you can tell he's tend to hit his eyes
are darting all over the place and did
you see that gesture he was like come on
let's go and uh surely he's going to
push that pawn is he there we go we have
it Gary the g-pawn makes an appearance
G5 he's going for magnus's king and very
famously Magnus Carlson lost the game
with the white pieces in this kind of
opening against veslin to Paulo back in
the Saint Phil cup 2015 I was
commentating that action wow nearly a
decade ago yeah hard for me to remember
these things but Magnus he remembers
everything so he has bad memories facing
this type of position where black is
trying to bust open the king side the
black king it's nice and safe in the
center we're often taught to Castle our
Kings here you see Hikaru he is looking
into this position because he is aiming
right for Magnus Carlson's Monarch and
you see Magnus he needs to think right
now he can capture that pawn but it may
not be worth it it opens up lines in
front of his King and actually
concretely as well perhaps it just
doesn't work out because imagine you do
pick up the pawn and black can shift
that Rook that we were talking about the
king side Rook it would then come into
play the open file would be so telling
and we see these two players on the
screen they're so focused right now
Hikaru leaning back he says game on
Magnus will you take that pawn if you
don't I'm going to advance it regardless
opening up that g file I love to see it
and you know what they say in chess you
advance upon in the flank the best
response to that is open up the center
because black skin is still right there
where the game starts and Magnus plays
the most logical way to continue opens
up his Bishop the queen side bishop and
challenges Hikaru in the center asking
him to make a decision there's no
stopping Hikaru he just goes on with
Gary the Jeep on I love it well played
Hikaru you're going for the king now uh
no way back from here you've pretty much
gone all in in this game but this is
what you need to do you need to attack
the Giants of the game they hate it
Magnus once again where he can maneuver
he wants an endgame that he can control
but going for the king Magnus is not
going to be feeling comfortable no
matter how this game ends up so I love
what hikara is doing right now we have
to delve in and explore the chaos the
fire that's on board already and it's
only move nine and um okay Hikaru react
white steps forward with the pawn
hitting the Black Knight and will we see
a trade will we see some pieces come off
the board Magnus wants to at least calm
this game down by trading off pieces and
at least reaching a position that he
knows he has uh at least some level of
safety but uh yeah we'll uh delve into
those in a moment here we go and black
now has the option of taking this white
knight uh I guess his reply will be to
take this one and luckily no time for
black to continue opening up the white
king because this bishop is attacked
with check so I'm expecting a bishop
capture a queen coming out now and at
least without that set of knights on the
board it's going to be slightly easier
for white to defend the king I still
feel that Hikaru has some levels of
activity some hopes on this King side
but uh Magnus will be happier here what
do we think any alternatives to this
line the fact that he's still thinking
leads me to believe that he may not
capture the Knight and F3 because that
is the automatic response if he were
playing bullet chess and we know how
good both these players are in those
time Patrol you just take the Knight and
F3 give up your night he does in fact go
for it but I was thinking that Hikaru he
wants to reply instantly at every turn
so when Magnus takes on F3 he wanted his
response lined up he plays his Rook over
to Jade after this series of Trades and
I think Hikaru he knows that he needs to
use the clock to his benefit he wants to
put Max in time trouble the issue though
is that White's King does not feel wide
open there's just one Rook staring at
the king there's a bishop a queen
defending that pawn over there and
Black's King remains in the center it's
not going to easily Castle Queen side
either so I think that for now Hikaru is
doing just fine but I don't think
there's any weaknesses in magnus's Camp
either I completely agree with Robert
you know we've been talking about this
open G file and hecaris managed to do
that but this sort of gives me the
nightmares from that game one where with
the black pieces Hikaru just went all
out took too many committal decisions in
the opening only to be backfired and
left with more weaknesses now talking
about black skin in the center it just
feels like that's the more vulnerable
King why does got a simple plan develop
that Bishop take that Bishop out you can
go all the way to F4 bring that Queen
side Rook to the center of the game
Target that Queen and then what you're
looking for at some opportune moment is
that Knight jumping to D5 or that pawn
from E4 moving up to E5 opening up both
the files and it just looks like yes you
open the G file but show me the money
show me the attack and I'm not finding
it for Hikaru yeah I'm not seeing it yet
either it definitely feels like your car
really needs to take some time out maybe
try to get this King over to safety on
the queen side uh in the near future but
uh he's in the tank right now I like
what he's done still but uh Magnus doing
a good job of locking it down okay he
needs to speed up Hikaru and wow a rook
move a quirky little move here lifting
up defending his Knight maybe the idea
is to slide the bishop out behind it to
this uh long diagonal maybe he's just
over protecting his Knight so he can
push his Pawn forward and take some more
control over Central's quest to try and
deter your idea at least Tanya but
um still it's very tempting to jump in
with the White Knight now or over the
next few moves I'm starting to think
that Magnus here has decent chances if
he can keep his nerves in check if he
wins this game he will win the
tournament what seems to be magnus's
intentions in this game is it to just
win it well he he's reacting so far so
he of course would like to win it now
that we've arrived at this point but
Hikaru said from his very first move I'm
not going to allow you to make a draw
and we've said this before you don't
really like to poke the bear now that
you're forcing Magnus to play a game we
look at the position White's King is
actually safe and sound over here so
unless black gets a few turns to get the
king castled queen side bring that
second Rook into the attack it feels
like white is just first to the action
the black king still in the center of
the board the White Knight able to hop
forward into that D5 Square I think that
Magnus his action has been more or less
kind of easy for him just because he had
no other choices and for Hikaru we have
to praise him for his mentality for the
fight that he's bringing but I do think
that it's harder for black to play in a
position like this yep suddenly harder
for black to play but Hikaru he's so
Universal he can yeah as long as he has
an imbalance or two he can work his
magic there so uh now okay clocks around
level
I don't see why Magnus is hesitating to
be honest just bring pieces into the
game as Tanya was advocating bring that
white Dart score Bishop out bring that
white rook in the corner towards the
center looks very natural but I think it
is just the effect of the Nakamura
approaching this game going for Magnus
not showing any fear that has forced
Magnus to pause to slow down he spent
two minutes on this move and it feels
like uh he has a couple of natural
alternatives So eventually he'll make a
decision and uh Hikaru will have his
reply ready they're not yet in each
other's camps all the white pieces on
one side of the board are okay
well I kind of like that typing it's
this Magnus sort of going for hikaru's
King now he is especially if this Knight
is captured black can choose which piece
to take this Knight with but if the
Black Knight or the black Bishop capture
this white knight suddenly it will be
replaced by a pawn and the e-file will
be open White's Rook on the Central File
will be staring down the black king and
that black king ain't gonna be feeling
comfortable so I'm expecting Hikaru to
dodge this trade not at least capture on
White's terms either you wait or you
Retreat the Black Knight those feel like
the only two options right now it would
be absolutely hideous for black to take
that Knight on D5 and open up the E5
with that King still stuck on E8 but he
needs to be careful about how he decides
not to let that happen and a car making
more committed decisions on the board
more Pawn pushes and instead of
developing the pieces here this can turn
bad really quickly he goes for E5 he's
trying to just block the position but it
just feels as if there have to be some
tactics here Black's King's still in the
center do you just wait right now do you
simply develop your Bishop is Bishop G5
a move
might be too much because then black
actually picks up the night it was a
nice little idea and maybe we can at
some point show it that you can get
tempted to improve your to develop your
Bishop but you have to watch out Black's
got his own Army black does have that
Bishop that can't pick up the knight at
any point so not a good idea to rush in
with that he instead decides to really
break in Black spawn structure with B4
just shifts the play to the other side
of the board yeah throwing a pawn
forward and uh forcing Hikaru to start
looking for weaknesses or looking at his
own weaknesses actually all over the
board and really interesting I've got to
say by Magnus he's just banking on the
fact that Black's pieces aren't ready
for the position to open up yet
especially that black king in the center
if lines do open that will be the one
under Fire and I'm trying to work out
the consequences here I'm not sure if it
is a pawn sacrifice Perhaps it is short
term for Magnus Carlsen but either way
um very logical move very ambitious move
showing Magnus isn't playing for the
draw he's following that conventional
wisdom that even though a draw is fine
for him he wants to win he wants to
settle it here and now yeah the only way
to win upon as David is highlighting is
that black has a part with the bishop
pair but by taking this Knight in D5 no
matter how you take it you open up the
board so let's say Bishop takes D5 the
pawn takes back and now you say give me
that B4 Pawn all is good the white
Bishop can slide up to D3 hit this Rook
on G6 and you just see the free-flowing
nature of whites pieces the A1 Rook can
slide one file over to B1 and that's why
Hikaru avoided this all together he says
it's not worth the pawn I'm probably not
going to be able to keep it my king is
in the center so instead he just takes
this Pawn on B4 the Knight just
recaptures and I feel like with this
position opening up and the black king
in the center it's all good news for
Magnus all that said that in the long
term look at these pawns on the queen
side A2 and C2 they're split which means
if the Queens come off the board that's
a dream for Hikaru if the Queens come
off then white has some pawns to worry
about but with all the major pieces in
the open files that's good news from
magnus's Miners and his Rooks I don't
believe that there's going to be a long
term in this game with that black king
Style 28 it's hard to imagine the pieces
being traded off Magnus is wanting is
going to want to go for that King and
there are all these ideas of developing
the bishop bringing your Rook to the
center of the board advancing the C Pawn
further as well to create more problems
what black has achieved out of the
opening is just one open G file but
White's key piece that Bishop on F1 it
is a sweet Defender it just controls
everything watch out for one thing
though that Bishop from D7 can always
add that H3 Pawn right now magnus's
Queen defends it because the pawn on G2
is pinned but he needs to make sure he
doesn't move that Queen anywhere else
keeps it there I'm expecting developing
moves get the Rooks connected move the
pawn up Magnus decides not to wait he
wants to start with it takes control of
that D5 square and a further advance of
the C Pawn is always in the air breaking
up the center yeah really nice move just
keeping control but as you mentioned
that Tanya hinting that you might start
intrude invading at some point later and
here as Hikaru I would be wanting to
curl up into a ball maybe just put the
bishop in front of my king just say okay
you're never getting past these pieces
that's a perfect uh defensive formation
but okay your other idea now on the
board Tanya I'm loving how you're
predicting everything this tournament uh
instead of that after the pawn marched
forward your car just shuffles his Queen
across not the most subtle threat this
one is pretty obvious but he does want
to capture this Pawn uh you utilizing
the pin I'm expecting magnets just to
shuffle into the corner at some point
and say okay no more pin on the G file
meaning uh that this Pawn on H3 is not
up for grabs interesting move uh it
feels like a one mover but at least he's
forcing Magnus onto the defensive and if
chorus King might have to stay in the
center so if that's the case he might
throw that B Pawn up the board as well
so he's aiming in all directions he's
like throwing darts with a blindfold on
he's hoping that he lands the good
numbers but it's just looking promising
for white one move threats from Black's
perspective easy to take care of and we
see actually now that car brings his
dark Square Bishop out to H6 the good
news is Rook May Len uh in where the
bishop is right now after a trade and
attacked the white king the bad news is
this D6 Pawn is a permanent weakness and
the dark Square Bishop was the only
piece covering it so it's a pro and con
situation I really love magnus's
position it just seems much healthier
yep and again the question for Magnus is
do you trade on Black's terms or do you
wait for black to exchange you so uh for
example this bishop trade now helps the
BlackRock get closer to the white king
along this line but if you wait I'm not
sure exactly how you wait but if you
wait for a move for example push upon
then yes black can trade but it's on
your terms you improve your white Rook
on the in the process and suddenly this
white Rook will be supporting uh the
motoring forward of this Pawn a bit
later so I'm expecting Magnus not just
to go for that yet okay he plays a very
useful move first of all he opens up his
Rook on the semi-open B file and
potentially Targets later watch out for
this Pawn being a weakness long term so
Black's position full of weaknesses but
his p cases are relatively active right
now that's the payoff that he's got for
all these committal decisions I love
that last move he just brings the other
Rook into the game saying that if you
take the bishop I'm gonna pick up the
bishop with my Rook on on the Central
File currently and then we'll see both
of White's Rook just in the best places
in the position really targeting that
queen as well as that pawn on B7 the
Knight can't jump to the center of the
board it looks like very aggressive play
by Hikaru in the opening is only reaping
rewards from Magnus currently with
blacks King stuck in the center with the
long-term weakness of that pawn in front
of the bishop as well as the queen side
backward B7 Pawn Hikaru for now tries to
get the king to safety he's sort of
doing this unnatural castling this where
he just marches with the King to safety
towards the king side but it's going to
use a lot of time meanwhile Magnus can
continue with development and Target the
weaknesses in Black Bond structure yeah
castling by hand they call it and
actually every game now I think three
games out of three we've seen one side
castle one side not Castle just move
their King instead a bit of a trender
but uh yeah meanwhile that black king
looks pretty safe hiding behind its own
pieces right now
um so a very logical move and as Tanya
says we're expecting Magnus to up some
pressure still maybe maintain the
tension between the dark Square Bishops
maybe just Shuffle her across that black
D6 Pawn the backward Pawn on that square
that we highlighted earlier still the
Target still you have to go for it at
some point as white the bar is inching
up for Magnus Carlson with the white
pieces if he wins it he will win the air
things Masters I do see some selfies
with several people cheering for Hikaru
Nakamura he needs at least to draw and
he has to win either this one or the
next game
it's intense for Hikaru Nakamura right
now and he is taking down to six minutes
on the clock but he has the advantage on
the clock right now he really does need
all the support he can get and uh I the
last move that Magnus made I mean it is
so counter-intuitive because we've been
talking about that weak D6 Pawn then
Magnus instead jumps in with the Knight
trades it he fixes the center only
because he wants Bishop activity at some
point and this I wasn't expecting that
because I really liked that black had
that weakness on D6 but now he sort of
made sure that he can't get through to
that Magnus it's a little surprising for
me what he's done yeah so he's kind of
connected his own Pawns in the center
here Magnus Carlson those two white
Central pawns now look uh pretty
impressive but he's also covered Black's
weaknesses it makes him harder for the
white Rooks to find a job to be employed
here I guess there's still the semi-open
b-file maybe white will Stack Up Rooks
on over there later but I think the
problem for Hikaru is how to get active
the black king is always going to be
slightly open that black Rook looks a
bit redundant now on the king side on
the h-file I don't think you've got any
attack now that all of the knights are
off of the board and the other Rook
still at home not connecting with its
pieces it's all these tiny small
problems for black adding up maybe into
a bigger issue yeah as you're saying
black lacks Harmony The Rook on H6 it
looked like a great aggressive piece now
we're just staring at a brick wall
protected Pawn structure for white in
front of his King but B5 is shot from
Makara Nakamura but it's not an active
shot I think it's actually a defensive
one he saw that pawn on B7 as a
long-term weakness he said let's trade
it off and he wants to activate the Rook
near his Queen it hasn't moved but you
can activate it and it's starting square
if pawns are traded in front of it so if
white decides to take on B5 black takes
back and you'll see The Rook on it stare
all the way down towards that pawn on A2
so that's good news for Hikaru but I
also think for uh Magnus I mean he can
just go for something like this all he
needs is to draw the next two games so
at worst comes the worst he just takes
this Pawn on B5 and enters a position
where he is risking absolutely nothing
his King is fine black king not doing so
badly with the limited material but
there's no way Magnus Carlson loses a
position like this yeah we've been
talking David about trading on your own
terms and this line is an option white
can also just look at in the initial
position bringing that Rook to the other
open file where you say yeah sure you
can get rid of that beep on weakness but
I am going to Target your queen get my
Rooks into the game so some pleasant
options here for Magnus how he decides
to find a solution to hikaru's last move
which asks him the question what do you
want to do with that C4 Pawn I'm liking
magnus's chances more and more and I'm
still thinking about that night trade in
the center is just such a classy move
because it's really something that not
many of us would think about but this is
the world champion he's always thinking
out of the box yeah and here you asked
the black queen what's she gonna do uh
what you're gonna do when they come for
you and that black queen is not happy at
all I'm trying to look for safe squares
actually if she has to shuffle to one
side then again this variation that
Robert showed for example trading
everything off suddenly the white Rooks
have easy access into the seventh Rank
and I would be fearful for Black's Life
In A variation like this maybe you can
defend by kind of getting across with
your Rook but it does look a bit scary
and either of these two white Rooks
could start infiltrating the black Camp
later on I love that idea Tanya and
looks like Magnus thinking for a long
time now but uh he might come up with
that one bad boy bad boy
both of them bad boys they're beasts on
them but mag is down to under just about
three minutes it seems and he does
decide to trade and probably it's the
match situation influencing him no risk
involved with this exchange and the
bishops come off all of a sudden we have
Queen two Rooks and four pawns per side
nothing really to write home about but
for Magnus Carlsen probably just want to
limit all risk and if he can play for a
win from there he will but he just does
not want to lose yeah and Hikaru needs
to keep some time Advantage if he wants
to win this game I think uh Robert spot
on with his prediction there is just
balance it's now it looks very level
after a bishop trade after that black
Rook on the a file goes to grab that
pawn back but uh yeah he needs to hustle
on the clock maybe put some magnets on
the some pressure there at least set the
tone set the foundations for the final
game of the day uh if this one is a draw
you need to make sure that Magnus goes
into it in a negative passive mindset
and okay that whole sequence that we
predicted on the board now big threat on
the board White's Rook wants to lift
itself up to the eighth rank pinning
that black queen winning that black
queen but uh of course Nakamura has a
timeout he gets his King to safety first
before anything too bad happens and uh
still tense now white can actually put
his Rook on the seventh rank as well
Magnus can Target that F7 weakness
bringing his Rook into the game into the
attack it just looks like if anyone's
putting any pressure in this position
it's got to be white on Black's King
Black's Queen is going to be tied down
to defending so many weaknesses this one
is playing for two results for white
either it ends in a draw or Magnus wins
and wins the champion Dr makter Stein
and the twitch chat saying Magnus it's
it's ending it in this game but uh
someone else pointing out that Magnus is
getting long time though and taking down
to two and a half minutes Magnus Carlson
that's never a good sign it does plant a
seed of doubts in your mind especially
when you've been ahead on the clock
throughout the whole day as Magnus has
been uh but there we go he drops a rook
on that black back rank on the eighth
rank attacking the black queen and you
have to be slightly careful where you
plant her I think you have to run down
the C file somewhere you have plenty of
choice I'm not sure which is the most
accurate square but you've got to be
careful some attacks potentially against
the black king I'd be going Queen C4 he
chooses the more aggressive approach I
thought Queen C4 to slide over to F4 if
the black queen is in front of the White
Queen with check those Queens come off
the board I know it looks like an ugly
Pawn structure but with limited material
it should actually be an easy hold for
akaro but he says let's keep them on the
board because if now the Queens are
swapped somehow Black's Pawn structure
is healthier the pawn on D5 is an
isolated Pawn that black can go after
now immediate pressure on the F2 Pawn as
well hikar saying let's give us both
chances here but we're not just going to
make a straightforward draw yeah I
really like that move like you said
Robert maybe going to another Square was
safer but this one at least asks
questions of Magnuson Down Under the two
minute Mark Magnus needs to play
actively he needs to stop playing
accurately as well because suddenly
the third result is in the picture maybe
it's not as safe as we've been
predicting for him but there we go he
jumps in it's like black is invaded the
white Army uh the white Camp whites
invaded the black camp and uh whose
attack is going to pay off first big
strike but black big threat but black
can fall back with the queen I was also
going to say black and come in with the
rook and defend and attack White Queen
it would have resulted in a couple of
checks but instead Hikaru falls back
with the queen not allowing any
perpetuals that would have been possible
in the other line and it still looks
like it's getting tricky for white wow I
love this move that he's played he
simply brings back The Rook we talk
about a rook lift this is a rook retreat
with the same idea of transferring a
rook from the queen side all the way to
the king side Rook G4 is a massive
threat on the board pinning that Queen
to that King and how is black going to
stop that can I just shout out this uh
tweet we have here they're cheering for
the Hess and chess
that's an automatic winner so cheers to
you too you must have heard that before
Hess and Chester of course yeah the
countless times
all that stuff so a shout out to Luisa I
appreciate that but this position right
now there is a big threat The Rook just
slid up to the B4 square meter trying to
go over in front of the queen with a pin
so hikara's task is actually not that
simple here it's not just let's just
trade pieces because those Rooks for
white are just more coordinated and more
active than that the blackworks
especially that Rook next to the queen I
think that work actually just slide up
one square to meet the white Rook
sliding to the G file with the blackwork
sliding in front so you're just trying
to trade off pieces as quickly as
possible yeah maybe we can check out
stockfish's top moves here because black
is on the defensive how big is the
margin for error how many moves do you
have okay only two moves to survive in
this game and both of them use the same
square so either the black queen has to
slide to the H5 square or the black Rook
that we said that Robert was
highlighting as being caged a bit
trapped needs to slide down one square
neither of those are obvious I've got to
say wow they both do react they do get
ready to counter a white Strat of The
Rook sliding but I'm not sure I'd find
that with only two minutes left on the
clock maybe we show this on the board as
well uh two moves now for the Carter to
stay in the game keep the balance is he
gonna find them either Queen to H5 okay
he is very good all these top players if
you give them a narrow pass they will
navigate their way but uh the idea here
is to meet this check with a block
suddenly this unemployed black Rook
finds a job and now the trade here will
make Black's defensive task easier
really really great uh resourceful
tenacious move there from Hikaru and so
on important in a very critical moment
where it's so easy to go wrong he does
find the right way but this just means
that pieces get traded off and Magnus
inches closer towards that draw which he
can't be too unhappy about with just one
round to go which would mean that Hikaru
has to throw yeah the kitchen sink at
him does everything Queen H5 played and
now Magnus is thinking does he go in
with the check which would also trade a
pair of Rooks or does he immediately
trade Queens I don't think a third
option do you think Magnus wants to keep
the Queens on the board and keep the
pressure on I think Magnus should just
want to get out of this game with a draw
now under 40 seconds on the clock
suddenly if he keeps the tension there
we go he gets the coins off but if he
keeps the tension suddenly Hikaru might
start getting ambitious he might start
hustling him but look at that black Rook
now on the second rank eyeing up some
pawns still not over still not
completely safe for white he gives a
check forcing the black king out of its
hiding place and uh I still think three
results possible despite the reduced
material despite the fact it's a rook
end game and it has naturally Jurish
Tendencies I think Hikaru has some small
chances but he doesn't look too happy
shaking his head there maybe this last
move by Matt just by Magnus really
accurate forcing uh forcing a repetition
yeah there might be a repetition that
you're talking about with the King
falling backwards uh controlling that D6
Pawn but none of that happens because
Hikaru really just wants to play this
till the very end instead of Defending
that point on going for a passive
defense which would have probably ended
in a repetition he picks up the F2 Pawn
but this can get dangerous now I think
if anyone's better it's black so I think
that Magnus now has to give the check
and he's doing just that he'll give this
King all the checks and there's nowhere
for the king to escape because the king
tries to run away to the queen side
let's say King goes back to the uh back
rank then the F7 Pawn would have been
hanging so instead we see the king go up
and it will go back if you're King F5
here with shikaru you know he wants to
play that could be playing with fire and
he may be the one who gets burned the
king all the way up the board it's not
helping oh and he goes for it okay risks
it for the biscuit and uh that white
Rook now the white rook and G4 is gonna
move there's gonna be massive of threats
if I still know Checkmate threats
because that white Pawn on G2 is pinned
but there we go that black king in big
danger but Hikaru he's performing a
balancing actor tightropeak with that
black king it's surviving for now but
that black Rook on the side of the board
also offside and white white porn sorry
it's racing forward Magnus making that
move with three seconds on the clock
well this one could still go either way
I love the risks sakaru is taking but he
looks nervous right now and how can he
back up that bravery that act of Courage
of advancing his King it's so important
that The Rook on D2 pins the G Pawn
because G4 check would have forked the
King of The Rook now the Rooks come off
the board and Black's Pawn structure is
healthier we see a pass Pawn on D6 but
it's also a liability because when
Black's King Ventures backwards you
could scoop up that pawn so this is
critical territory from Magnus Carlson
with just seconds on his clock and look
at Hikaru he is digging in he wants to
take this game yeah he's feeling
confident and you're right there Robert
Black's Rook is active blacks Rook is
actually tying down the white king
eyeing up that white Pawn but okay
what's happened here Hikaru reacting
laughing because now the white Rook is
going to retreat perhaps he's a pawn up
he's keep playing and the reason is
because a white can switch The Rook from
the check to attacking that H Pawn and
then black will at some point have to
give that up I'm not sure why is why is
Hikaru laughing because there's a
critical line right here if we can
actually analyze and this might just
happen I think he sees Magnus bring his
Rook down to G4 but block it off you see
a car he points the finger he said maybe
this is a winning end game Rook D4 for
black that is the critical line you
sacrifice a Pawn on the DeForest where
he has played it and Matt says I can't
trade it's a Magnus the analysis Bar
says that would have been a winning end
game for black instead Magnus he saw
through that he keeps the Rooks on the
board but that's why Hikaru was upset he
thought it'd be immediately draw then he
said no no no the king of Pawn game
would have been winning for black yeah
now he's simply a pawn up and he can try
and nurse this to it to Victory he's
just gonna Advance these pawns slowly
and steadily he's got great winning
chances Hikaru Magnus down at only 12
seconds we were showing a line that
could have happened the king of Paul
nine game where Hikaru would have won
but Magnus did Dodge it successfully and
the game goes on now this is going to be
a long ride but it's all about these two
pawns those Central pawns for Hikaru the
look at the bar on the live board as
well and the clock is ticking for Magnus
scene 11 10 seconds left for the world
number one and a really difficult
position to hold because Hikaru can just
play Forever he's got to push those
pawns at some point get that King into
the game these are real winning chances
here for black it's the best position
that hikaru's had all match it all comes
down to this but what a turnaround and
what a way to make this a possibility
just hats off to Hikaru for doing this
he needs to get this game now he needs
to win this one if he doesn't then I
fear that the match will be over in the
next one Magnus will feel he has a
second life but okay just repeating now
Hikaru not committing to a plan yeah the
last couple of moves just shows that
he's not really sure where that winning
technique is what is that winning plan
he of course has to shuffle around a bit
with every move he gets three seconds on
the clock but he needs to keep that
pressure on magnus's clock as well yeah
the problem is for black as you really
would like to take this G2 Pawn for the
H4 Pawn like release your own Rook uh
that would be good you want connected
past pawns that are unopposed but Magnus
is not allowing that he's giving the
king a bunch of checks you could run
forward but then the Rook will continue
to follow the king push it to the other
side of the board and then start going
after the black pawns so this is exactly
what Magnus is doing hikara has to step
back and look at this back and forth
shuffling pieces the H4 Pawn remains a
Target the Black Brook has to stay
passively defending rather than going
after White's pawns yeah but that may be
Black's uh plan should have been to get
the Rook to the second rank to tie down
that white king to the G Pawn you
mentioned Robert that you have to go for
that trade you have to get that
remaining uh White Pawn on G2 in order
to get your central pawns rolling and
now he's kind of tied up his own Rook
Hikaru I don't like where the BlackRock
is placed it's in front of its own pawns
blocking your only plan of advancing
them and now really classy for Magnus he
just cuts off the black king the black
king now can never step down the board
to the sixth Rank and uh has to start
marching over to harass that Rook but
again Magnus is going to start attacking
some pawns just keeping those black
pieces honest keeping the black record
King tied down maybe Magnus is going to
get the draw of the bar back closer
towards the center but okay now decision
time for Hikaru do you surrender your
central pawns and go for white spawns no
you have to keep your pawns intact in
the middle just to keep some chances
alive an important theoretical end game
is if white loses both pawns for the E5
Pawn that is a theoretical draw I know
from experience I had that position
against vishnath and Anand I had the two
pawns he held the draw and so it's
something that both players know and
that's why hikar is clinging on to this
epon he pushes it Forward he connects it
with his other pawn and that will create
threats if the black king gets active
that black king were on the fourth or
fifth rank up to G5 that would be good
news but the king is cut off magnus's
Rook is in the perfect position yeah if
that King was better placed that black
king I think he'd be winning Hikaru but
he's going for it now he's pushing his
pawns without his King oh this is either
very good or it will blow the winning
chances I do fear for Hikaru that
actually now the black Rook is stuck
defending its own pawns you need to
connect the king with your pieces with
the rest of your army Magnus can he hold
this one with less than 10 seconds he's
doing all the right things so far the
most important thing for Magnus is to
make sure that black skin doesn't
advance and that's what he does he does
keep the king blocked but the bar does
not approve of that and I'm wondering
why not does black have something really
strong the winning plan is not going to
be obvious for any human here let alone
these players with only a few seconds
left on their clock and I'm expecting
hikara to move his Rook away at some
point you need to activate those black
pawns at the moment everything's a bit
stuck black Rook needs to move Magnus
Carlson doesn't believe in fortresses he
famously said that but I do think that
we could see a fortress here I know the
eval bar looks like it's great for black
but sometimes you can't actually break
through but look the group Retreats that
means the black king could step forward
that is not good news for Magnus and
watch out for Hikaru to bring his King
up and then push his F4 Pawn to F3 just
jettison that pawn so his King can enter
the position and go for checkmating
ideas yeah note how Hikaru just from
time to time he repeats the position
just to put the pressure back on Magnus
uh just to say okay I'm in control uh
you win definitely not going for a draw
but I'm just going to tease you with
that and look at this suddenly the white
Rook moves what's happening can the
black Rook make Headway against the lone
white king maybe you needed to check
from the bottom of the board and then go
behind the white king is Hikaru winning
it feels like he should be the black
king is so active now we said as long as
the black king joins the action you're
winning but what's the killer plan
there's something in the position he's
trying to calculate and that is the
right thing to do he knows that he's
made maximum progress but where is the
kill of low here he's going to bring his
King all the way in at some point his
Rook is going to be released from the
app file somewhere along the second Rank
and the black king is a stake for a D4
D3 into E2 and whoa he plays F3 right
away and was that a good choice I'm
surprised he committed with uh with so
little time on the clock he could have
repeated and gone back to this Robert
earlier you mentioned the F Pawn and
each Pawn together is a draw but E Pawn
and H Pawn is winning because they're so
far apart White's defenses will be
stretched can the black can come in now
is it still winning this is so close it
does look like because you every time
you do move your Rook away from him
white king steps forward and everything
is under control he's got to get the
king into the attack to save to help
that e-pawn Advance further I'm
expecting a king Advance right now but
watch out for a rook check that might
pick up the H Pawn Yeah you have to be
careful where you put the black king
right now you don't want to allow any
nasty checks from the white Rook behind
Okay he Retreats his Rook really clever
now look at the white king it's cut off
it can never move towards that black
Central Pawn because the black Cuts
along the file and Hikaru Bobs his head
he thinks he's winning it does look very
strong the king is coming now wait but
he's gonna check how is he going to run
away because King goes to the C file The
Rook just slides over and you can't push
the E point and now they're you're more
distance from the king so the King goes
to D3 you see the bar go back to equal
so react to Karu as well oh my gosh yeah
I thought he's still a great winning
chance but he loves the king forward but
then the Rook comes the G3 with check so
that's why Magnus slides backwards and
his King is no longer cut off that means
that Magnus Carlson should be able to
hold yeah Hikaru maybe there was a more
accurate way of doing it it wasn't easy
even if it was winning and suddenly
magnus's Rook is active suddenly you can
start giving checks from the side and
now he wants to come with the King to
the other side he wants to create an
opposition and try and attack white skin
create a meeting net but Magnus slides
all the way back with the Rook to give
backward checks to black skin and this
just looks like with the black Rook
stuck here there will be no saving the
blacking from checks anymore we're gonna
see a hundred checks but the result will
be the same this will end in a draw wow
nowhere safe to hide if the black Rook
could move away the black king could
hide in front of its own pawns or his
own H Pawn but now there's nowhere
there's nowhere safe if you have to
start retreating the black king towards
the white Rook then suddenly your pawns
might drop off and look at kikaru he's
so frustrated right now and it's the
wrong Pawn the H Pawn so if the King
goes back the white king steps forward
The Rook will take this Pawn on E3 and
the king is inside the square one king
at pawning games you're trying to chase
down the pawn you make a square to the
promotion uh point and here he oats okay
H3 the pawn goes forward still alive and
no more progress I think black is
completely Frozen now aha but uh what
happens once the black king starts
running over still nowhere to hide I
guess and uh okay we're past the 100
move mark this has been a marathon game
can Hikaru squeeze out a win what a
fight Magnus thinks he's drawing he lent
back there looking very happy with
himself but still chances are live I
agree with Robert I think it's the wrong
point the black Rook is just on the
worst possible Square tie down defending
both of them the blackrook is passive
you need active pieces to win these
types of end games
well what a miracle this is if Magnus
holds and it's just it's just amazing
the defense that he's shown and we can
see Hikaru that he's giving up on this
he knows that there's no way to improve
this position further the blacks Rook is
tied down to defending that E3 pawn and
the H3 Pawn Magnus continues to attack
the black king with checks there's no
place to hide and we see yakahikaru
leaning back he knows he's done
everything but it's not been enough
so so close but no cigar down under 10
seconds now Hikaru he looks like he's
about to give up his winning attempts
about to agree that draw just all the
checks look at that black king so sad
has to retreat the whole way back and
this pattern is just going to continue
the black King's going to chase the
white Rook but to no avail the uh White
Rook is just going to move hide check
and cause all the problems in the world
and at this point here Cara might just
be going for the longest game in
Champions chest or history because we're
at move 116 it seems and it's going to
keep going because a car is just going
to hope for a Magnus Carlsen mistake but
the issue for Hikaru his Rook is
completely Frozen in place if it ever
leaves the third rank the pawns are
going to fall off and the King it wants
help out and protecting the pawns but
the Rook keeps checking so as long as
the king is far away from The Rook The
Rook keeps checking it and the King has
nowhere to hide
and we see that happening and now he
just shifts back because there's nothing
to be done and it doesn't matter where
the King goes when the king gets closer
to the pawns Magnus starts checking it
driving it away
yeah no progress has been made over the
last 20 moves now Hikaru wow yeah can he
recover from this heartbreak and uh lots
of cheerleaders we see for Hikaru on
Twitter and yeah he's put up such a
fight I love everything Hikaru has done
this game just is that a hikachu hikachu
Hikaru or a Pikachu it's just so close
this is the most frustrating thing in
chess you do everything right your car
has literally not put a foot wrong this
game but
breaking the defenses of the world
number one that's another question
that's another level but there is
something you take away from it the fact
that Hikaru was able to create this
chance this opportunity with the black
pieces David earlier you were talking
about going into the last round on his
terms and that's what he's managed to
create he's made it clear that Magnus
needs to be careful there we have it
game three is a draw so close for Hikaru
Nakamura to make that comeback he is not
happy but he does still have another
chance game four will start in five
minutes that's gonna be must win for
Hikaru Nakamura what a game we have been
witnessing and here is today's Lisa
vetta learning point
foreign
[Music]
held this seemingly hopeless end game
against Hikaru Nakamura despite being a
pawn down despite having having a
passive King and despite Black's Pawn
being so strong and uh so close to
promotion here white started giving
checks from the side a very typical
pattern in a hurricane game and actually
black could have won if he'd chosen the
best squares for his King the way to get
out of these checks was to go away from
the black pawn to step down the board
and if white continues checking the
black king yes you're happy to step away
but now no more checks the white Rook
has to move and black with a rook jump
now would be winning simply the black
king will come round help the pawn from
the other side it's slow but surely
eventually winning instead Hikaru moved
his King to the wrong square and
suddenly no progress to be made all
these checks from the side all the
checks from the back later on in the
game saved Hikaru Nakamura so keep
trying to defend and Rook end games
they're very difficult study them
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
oh the drama you guys we still might
have are my
good tweet your predictions
will be the winning bid the lowest bid
in case of an armor get on tweet your
answer using the hashtag chess Champs
and the one who gets the closest to the
answer when this air things device
signed by Magnus Carlsen himself and
remember the special deal a hundred
dollars off air things if you use the QR
code on the bottom of the screen all
right we have to breathe let's take a
quick twitch break if you're not a
subscriber but if you are subscribing on
Twitch chess.com then we're going to
hang out here in the studio
foreign
[Music]
division one Grand Final with Magnus and
Hikaru division two grand final also
happening what's the status there Ivanka
yeah there was definitely drama there as
well because we left it the score was
even but Fabiano he just showed what a
world-class player he is because he
immediately struck back and won with the
white pieces and now they're playing
game four and now it's Fabi who is under
tremendous pressure you have to remember
Yu Yang Yi isn't a must-win situation he
needs to take it to Armageddon if he has
any chance for this Grand reset okay so
game four happening there it's must win
for you yangi to take it to uh
Armageddon and a potential reset same
situation for Hikaru Nakamura no he only
has five minutes to get ready for that
final game what do you think your car is
doing right now I mean the last game was
probably a little bit frustrating for
him so I would say shake it out you know
just take it move by move don't think
about the whole result or what happen
next focus on the chess all right and
maybe do some puzzles well probably
hasn't doesn't have time for that we do
have a really nice puzzle that you
brought with you today Ivanka what is uh
the thought behind this puzzle yeah it's
my favorite puzzle to be honest and I
love it so much and here we see it is
white to play please note that black has
two Queens on the board but Black's King
is in troubles and uh White does have a
winning continuation here
beautiful puzzle
Grand final game four must win for
Hikaru Nakamura is coming up in just a
few minutes
he cannot lose and he has to win either
this one or the next one
we have it Gary the g-pawn makes an
appearance G5 he's going for magnus's
kick the bar is inching up four Magnus
Carlsen with the white pieces
[Music]
wow what a game big big chances for
Hikaru to make that comeback eventually
a draw though and that means Hikaru has
to win game four do you think that was
his chance Robert or uh can he do it in
game four Hikaru it felt like roles were
reverse in that game it felt like Hikaru
was playing like Magnus and then Magnus
was defending like akaro these are two
Titans of online chess and for a car
it's going to be disappointing but he's
proven to himself that he can get an
advantage against Magnus Carlsen and
we'll see what he brings with the white
pieces but he's gonna have to give it
his all white pieces for Hikaru must win
what you expect David
um I'm not sure in terms of openings
because Hikaru can do everything but he
has to bring the same mentality not be
afraid to throw pawns forward like he
did in that previous game which
eventually gave him all those chances
and he calculated so well more
importantly he had a clock Advantage he
had an extra minute or two on the time
on the clock over Magnus throughout the
entire game and that really got him
close to Victory but in the meantime
repetition of game two of the day are we
surprised that her car is going back
into this opening and this is where it
changes what we saw was the queen trade
but the other the bishop Pawn had
Advanced up the board and it looks like
Hikaru did a little preparation he
switched it up a little but we still
have an end game the Queens have been
traded off as Robert likes to call it a
queenless uh middle game because there
every other piece is on the board now I
have to say when the match started and
Hikaru after losing that first game it
looked like mission impossible to even
come back into that match but what we
saw in game three it showed us what
Hikaru is capable of the pressure that
he's amounted on Magnus and Magnus knows
that it's not going to be easy with the
black pieces but I'm still surprised
that Hikaru has an approach to go for a
queen trade so early on in a
win-on-demand game
very rarely works against Magnus Carlson
to get the Queens off and somehow
outmaneuver him and it clearly looks
like Magnus has done his research too
well you said it rarely works but it
just almost worked to Perfection before
Hikaru Nakamura the Queens came off it
was an end game uh the evaluation bar
the computer said oh it's equal and the
car said not so fast I have a more
active King and he won upon in almost
the game but I feel like Hikaru is
misunderstood as this tactical player he
is a brilliant tactician we've seen him
do puzzle Rush we've seen his great
games under the duress on the clock but
he actually loves these intricate
positions with full subtleties and
nuances where he can just play a neutral
position I think that maybe this one
doesn't feel like a must-win position
because it's just a symmetrical
structure of both sides putting their
pieces in similar squares but I do think
that Hikaru definitely has what it takes
to win a position just like this even
against Magnus Carlsen yeah he
definitely has what it takes but it
feels like the next few moves are
critical because if black does get
organized if black does get Rooks to the
center challenging for the D file then
all the pieces are going to disappear
very fast from the board and Magnus
magnus's chances of drawing will be
increased with them so yeah it
definitely feels like Hikaru he's going
into the tank at the right moment he
needs to create some little imbalance at
least something for Magnus to sweat
about but uh it's not going to be easy
and with that last move a Magnus creates
a threat on the board he has spinned
that Knight as we can see to that Rook
on D1 and what he wanted to do was bring
his own Knight to the center of the
board Knight D4 was a huge threat on the
board making it taking advantage of that
pin Hikaru continues to develop stopping
that threat brings the bishop to the E3
Square connects the Rook what he wants
to do next is push that Rook one step
ahead also signaling at a doubling up
along the only open file on the board
you've got Rooks bring them on the open
files yep good uh good logic very good
strategy and now up to Magnus how is he
going to improve his position we know he
hates the castle the trend is has been
that one side castles and the other side
doesn't throughout this match so far
today but if he wants to connect the
Rooks if he wants to challenge for the
default he might have to commit at some
point to bring his King to this flank
just to get his rook in the game
also just want to point out one
interesting idea that blackout if we
just got one move back inside of Bishop
coming to E3 white could have also
thought about just pushing and provoking
that Bishop from G4 by the move H3 but
then again what we were talking about
Bishop trades the Knight and the Knight
jumps to D4 and now notice how that C2
Pawn is attacked and the bishop is
attacked and in fact this would have
resulted in Black winning a pawn so
Magnus that is setting up these Small
Tricks but of course Hikaru is ready for
them he made the right choice by
developing that Bishop he's very alert
right now yeah very alert so he's
covering this key square that the Black
Knight wanted to jump into I'm not
exactly sure what Magnus should be doing
for example if black does Castle again
awkward question now this bishop will be
challenged and if you don't want to
retreat with your head hanging low here
if you don't want to just admit that
you've lost a move then you will take
this Knight but suddenly imbalance two
Bishops yes it's a closed position in
the center but later on watch them come
to life so uh Hikaru has something to be
optimistic about in this position yeah I
think it's also tempting with an open
file to put your Rooks there white
already has a rook on the D file in the
live position and it black tries to
challenge right away that would actually
be a mistake we've been talking about
how Magnus is taking advantage of the
pin on the night The Rook takes the Rook
that eliminates the pin if you take with
the Knight you actually lose a pawn
immediately on E5 that would be a
blunder and if you take instead with the
King to keep that pawn protected the
Knight jumps the other way up to G5
there is no pin F7 is under attack I'm
gonna push my Pawn to H3 next my Rook is
still going to slide to the open file
and there's only one open line and white
is the one that's going to take control
of it the that it would be bad news for
Magnus that is why he's thinking here he
needs to be very careful it seems like a
position where you have countless
options all of which look good but it
does hand hit Cara a little something in
pretty much every line so he's just
trying to figure out the next five move
how he envisions the future yeah The
Five-Year Plan and uh now right now
Magnus is contemplating that and uh yeah
hikari's still got enough life left
despite the absence of Queens everything
else is still on the board so plenty of
ammunition left how big of an advantage
this is for your car now to to be in
control of that open file if significant
it's pretty much the only only thing
separating the two players right now if
Magnus does get two moves if Magnus
could Castle his King and then bring a
rook to the Central File it's going to
be equal it's going to be a draw so uh
Hikaru he's up half a Tempo that's what
we say when white starts uh starts the
game and especially in positions with
symmetrical Pawn structures that is
extremely relevant maybe the most
important factor Magnus now thinking for
three minutes he was down a lot on the
clock in game three again Hikaru has a
big advantage on the clock already
starting to slow down Magnus yeah maybe
it's the nerves uh I know that myself in
situations especially last rounds I get
so tense and uh I feel you know it's
really hard to kind of focus purely on
the moves to calculate you always start
double checking everything the stakes
are so much higher you can't blunder and
uh yes as I get older I feel that that
sets in more and more and of course
Magnus he's not that old but uh
definitely he slowed down at least in
this game and also the previous game but
this is is where Hikaru is the real
expert right time management in speeches
he's phenomenal at it I mean he just
plays all these great moves and he
spends little time doing so and he often
seems Invincible until he plays someone
like Magnus Carlson and I like what
Magnus has done because he pushes his
pawns And Trades off his Bishop for the
night but what he's been doing is taking
control of squares oftentimes we look at
chess and see tactics when we do our
training positions we're often looking
at how can I Checkmate my opponent or
win some material here he's making sure
that the Knight on C3 the only white
knight can't hop forward without a trade
and now the bishop on F3 won't jump to a
new diagonal because the pawn on H5
takes care of the G4 Square in the event
of a nitrate so I really like those last
two moves from Magnus Carls and he's
just taking care of his position he is
not taking it for granted every little
situation every little square it matters
yeah and maybe a plan a hidden plan if
he gets given the time the opportunity
he could try to remove White's Bishop
Hair by trading off the dot squared
Bishop later on this is by far White's
inferior Bishop it's blocked in by its
own Central Pawn this is the better
Bishop therefore and if you can trade it
off even if it comes at the cost of a
couple of Tempe it will be worth it so
Magnus hinting at that idea I don't
think you can rush to do that because
white will have time uh you could also
hint that you might push this Pawn
forward later just to break up the white
structure even further so a
multi-purpose move there from Magnus and
he has the time because the Queens are
off the board he doesn't need to commit
his King yet and he just throws the move
back to Hikaru and says okay you solved
the issue is this a threat you decide
and the other one that you were talking
about how comfortable is Hikaru allowing
Madness to further Advance with that H
Pawn all the way to H4 which will force
white to decide with his own kingside
pawns and perhaps creating more
weaknesses the only way to actually
counter that threat is to push your own
H Pawn one step ahead but every pawn
moves comes with its own set of
drawbacks and here it would be the
weakening of that light Square the one
on G4 that you're highlighting right now
David so it's very crucial for Hikaru to
really evaluate how dangerous is the
threat of the H Pawn advancing down the
board and it's never an easy call do you
push your own Pawn or do you allow that
to come forward just saying you know
what one day your Pawn might be a
weakness yeah and I've noticed that
especially in Rapid chess the players
they actually invest the most time when
they have to make strategic decisions
when it's about formulating that five
move plan and always the first step of
that plan is the most difficult that's
why we saw Magnus Carlson take two three
minutes out and then he played three
quick moves because it was all the rest
of his plan now hikar root is the one it
looks like he's suffering he's not he's
just envisaging a plan and whether
that's maybe rerouting this bishop
whether that's doubling up his Rooks as
Tanya mentioned earlier maybe shifting
this Rook up and the other one behind it
he's mulling over all of these in his
mind and then he'll decide the next
three or four moves will come fast
maneuvering for now remember everyone
this is must win for Hikaru Nakamura to
take the Grand Final to an Armageddon
also in the Armageddon Hikaru will have
to win it because he is coming from the
losers bracket that means Magnus Carlsen
he hasn't lost a single match so far in
the air things monsters and if he wins
the grand final he will be the winner of
the air things monsters Hikaru Nakamura
he needs to win the Grand Final to take
it to a grand final reset so he has to
win this game to take it to an
Armageddon and then also be the Victor
in Armageddon to take it to a reset it's
a lot to ask sounds like a lot of
winning yeah it's a lot to ask against
Magnus Carlsen but if anyone can do it
it is Hikaru Nakamura but right now this
game it is must win for him guys
predictions are we getting an Armageddon
or not I'm just hoping for it I'm just
really hoping for another Armageddon I'm
gonna say no just because I believe in
magnus's defensive skills and in such a
simplified position it's hard to see him
going wrong uh just from experience he's
the master at uh working his magic in
these types of positions Robert well for
the first time you've allowed me to
agree with you because you know what I'm
going to say and then you say the
opposite yeah I think that Magnus
Carlson has this one under his control
especially after hikaru's last move he
brings his Bishop to attack the Knight
on F6 but he's allowed the Black Knight
to hop into the center so I just feel
like Magnus doesn't really have true
weaknesses in his position it's kind of
simple for him to play now and unless
I'm overlooking something maybe Hikaru
has a hidden idea up his sleeve I
believe Magnus has this one under
control and he's ahead in the clock I
have some news for you guys we have a
result Fabiano caruana is the winner of
division two it was a draw in game four
a huge win for Fabiano Corona winning
ten thousand dollars for winning
division two in the air things Masters
she is also now qualified for event two
in the Champions chess tour 2023 that
means we will see Magnus Carlsen Hikaru
Nakamura Wesley so and Fabiano Corona in
event two what did I know I know
incredible right just amazing stuff I
mean these are the four big names and
we're gonna see them fight against each
other we could not have asked for a
better lineup this is going to be an
amazing event but this one akaya still
continues the line that you were talking
about Robert is on the board with black
jumping up with the Knight guys I cannot
wait just thinking about Wesley Magnus
Hikaru Fabi fight attack I know it just
it's such a start field yeah stacked
that's the way yeah yeah incredible feel
to imagine they could be joined by
faruga Nippon Nishi like a bunch of
other players and uh four other spots
for grabs there will be qualifiers
coming up a total of eight players we'll
fight it out as well in event two
and we're actually joined by Fabiano
carry on a huge congratulations on
winning division two Favi
thank you thanks
what has this be this week been like and
today's Grand final match with uh with
um yuyangi
yeah there were a lot of tough matches
uh I have to say the last one neither of
us played very well I mean
we we both had some very strange moments
especially I think when I lost in game
two and uh how he lost in game three
but yeah I mean I was uh also under
pressure in the last game it was
definitely a tough match it was funny
that I had to play Yankee twice
um first in the winners bracket and then
he he managed to get through the losers
bracket after I beat him the first time
uh but yeah very very happy that I
managed to uh to win I heard rumors that
you really have been working a lot on
speed chess and online chess lately is
that true
not really I mean it depends what you
mean by working on speeches like I I
play a lot of online events now because
because there's so many going on but I
don't do anything
like I don't even know what working on
speech has really means I guess just
playing a lot
yeah if that if that's what it means
then definitely I have played quite a
lot I mean I played in in almadi the
world championships and uh okay this was
quite a lot of Chess effects because the
preliminary State and I don't know how
many matches I played so it was
uh yeah quite a lot of speeches for sure
hey at Fabiano we are super excited here
in the studio fans are super excited
because for winning division two you
qualify for division one and event two
in the Champions chess tour what's that
mean to you
well it definitely gives me
um a good shot in the overall standings
at least it's a good start of course it
was it was a bit of a hard breaker to
um get eliminated from division one by
losing to to Serana
uh and after that I was already you know
a bit dejected about the whole
tournament but uh after going through
division two and I didn't even know
until yesterday that it actually
qualifies for division one that's that's
sort of an icing on the cake
yeah and Fabi you're used to playing the
two players who are duking out for
division one right now hikar Nakamura
Magnus Carlson what was it like playing
some of these very strong Grandmasters
who typically don't get the spotlight
that you face in division two
well it was interesting I
um for example I I was very worried
before I played uh yakubo because he had
just eliminated on draken and uh and I
had never played him before so it was a
bit of an unknown to me uh obviously
he's a young and and super Talent player
so you always get extra worried for
those kinds of matches and I was even a
bit happy to play Yankee because I'm
more familiar with his chest you know we
played I think the first time
10 years ago and and the World Cup in
Trump so so I like to play players who
who I know a little bit more about
um but it was also interesting to play
to play some guys who uh haven't let's
say made their their mark on top level
chess yet uh also because you get you
know well I'm so familiar playing let's
say guys like Hikaru or Wesley or Magnus
and and you get very familiar with those
types of players and then it's
interesting to play Someone fresh
Bobby congratulations on your win and I
have a lighter question we've all been
loving and enjoying your sea squared
boss podcasts and I want to ask you how
fun has that been for you and who's been
your favorite guest on it so far
uh it's been a lot of fun it's been very
different from what I've I've been used
to my entire career which is which is
playing chess I still very chess
centered of course
uh in in terms of my favorite guest well
we had some fun ones I I think Maurice
Maurice Ashley was very fun
um Levy Rosman who's a better known as
Gotham chess was a very fun one that was
very uh personal because we really I
think all of us opened up and we got a
good dialogue going on
um
and yeah there's been a lot of fun ones
so maybe those are the the two that
stick out most we also interviewed
Hikaru which was probably our most
watched one which was interesting
because
um you know Hikaru and I have always I
think viewed each other as Rivals for a
long time for you know well over a
decade I mean we were even playing when
when we were kids and he was a bit older
than me so to to speak to him in that
format was was very different so that
was interesting but yeah it's been a
very interesting project and uh if any
one of the viewers are looking first you
know some chess uh content definitely
check it out definitely Fabiano we are
super excited to see you in division one
in the next uh CCT event big
congratulations on your big win today
thank you thank you so much for joining
us and this match is still going on
Grand Final in division one it must win
for Hikaru Nakamura we've had several
moves on the board bring us up to speed
David yeah several moves but huge
developments Magnus Carlson now I think
has a small Advantage if anything and
the winning chances for Hikaru Nakamura
are minimal you see it on hikaru's face
right now the game has not gone that
well for him the pawn structure has been
clarified there's been a couple of Peace
trades since we last talked about the
position and Magnus is in full control
cruise control at this point uh the
Black Knight has gotten some nice juicy
squares to jump into the black Rooks as
soon as they uh combine that will be the
end of the fun and I think this game
won't go that much longer uh someone
contradict me please because I want some
entertainment I have a decisive result
but I don't see it happening
unfortunately
me neither I mean I really want to
contradict you because we're all hoping
for that Armageddon David but it's super
hard in this position and the factors
are as you mentioned that Black's night
just feels a lot more active we see that
F4 Square in the position where Black's
Knight can head it ask the same question
for that night that white has that
Hikaru has no good squares for it
meanwhile black spawn structure also has
a lot more Mobility I can imagine a
central break happening at some point
with that pawn next to Black's King
Magnus can advance it two steps ahead
play it on F5 once it is guarded in a
proper way and that would create so many
weaknesses it just feels like black has
all the trumps here the bigger plans in
the position well what are White's Rooks
doing what is that white knight doing
and it has no targets whatsoever Hikaru
Nakamura is currently on the defense
yeah and uh winning this game is another
matter yes you could probably draw it
with best play but uh let's check out
some ideas here just to show uh how
Magnus can control things and uh I mean
first move that came to my mind was
jumping in with the Knight just because
we looked for forcing moves first this
does gain time hitting the white Rook
the white Rook moves I'm not sure where
let's say it slides across and now this
Knight could plan itself either now or
in the next few moves on this nice
Square I guess the counter play here for
Nakamura would rely on this night
getting active I'm not sure that Magnus
will want to allow that uh hence maybe
his retreating move that he's chosen in
the game this Pawn would be under Fire
maybe the Knight could start jumping
into some loose squares um I was going
to say the alternative if we go back
would have been to Lock White Knight out
of that square out of any active squares
by pushing the support Magnus says okay
I'm not even going to weaken my
structure he drops back and now some
nasty night checks to watch out for if
you're not careful and if Hikaru does
get active with this Knight Magnus can
just take a time out to defend this Pawn
uh with his own pawn and still hard to
imagine anything going wrong for a black
I think Magnus is playing the match
score because if he was just playing a
game for start of a tournament he
probably would have ventured forward
with his Knight but he does not want to
allow hitkara's Knight to get to the A5
Square for example because if that
Knight is over there both the B7 and C6
pawns are under attack Now by bring his
Knight to E6 he just is keeping his
pieces closer to that side of the board
the Knight can in fact hop up to the C4
square and once black plays F6 yes that
Knight can in fact go to A5 uh there
isn't maybe immediately the biggest
threat because if the Knight takes on B7
perhaps The Rook slides over to B8 but
you have to be very careful when you
give up pawns on that side of the board
I actually do think it would be hanging
so you would have to slide The Rook over
to defend but I mean this at least gives
Hikaru some hope I mean there is an
active Knight for white and that's
exactly what he's going for yeah it's
what he has to go for if he wants to win
this game and maybe the problem here is
that you're not quite in time for white
if you had one more move to double up
your Rooks now and infiltrate the black
Camp then great you might be able to win
but to here black can neutralize this by
bring bringing his own Rook back and
sliding across just one trade of rocks
is enough to ensure that white Rooks
never ever get into the black Camp it's
important as well that uh in a line like
this one that the Black Knight is on
this Square because after Rook takes
Rook the Knight jumps back to defend
everything and here if all the Rooks
disappear symmetrical structure white
will never win this game uh he's going
for it and I think the safest at least
is to go back with the black Rook maybe
Magnus contemplating going more
ambitious no he chooses a safe approach
I was gonna say you could deliver a
check but why bother you only need to
draw and once The Rook lands on d8 your
Karu is gonna struggle for winning
chances no we want armaged on
this is such a clinical way to play he
just goes for the idea of getting all
the pieces off the board and an end game
with just the knights it looks like it's
going to be the white ones that will
need defense defending once the Knight
comes back into action after the Rooks
are traded off we all won the Armageddon
but this that looks like a far-off dream
right now
yeah this dream and okay Magnus takes
back with his Knight a pair of rocks
there is a funny trap though so if we
can bring an analysis board to be very
very careful because black wants to make
the next move Pawn to B6 that would be a
huge blunder if white plays let's say B3
some calm move and you played B6 hoping
to kick net Rook takes Knight is
available for white because when the
Knight takes on C6 for white that is a
fork no matter how black recapture so
and that's the one thing Magnus look out
for he has successfully done that he is
not going to fall victim to such a
tactical shot yeah really nice geometry
there though to show the pitfalls that
still lie await and wait for black and
okay meanwhile Hikaru has given up a
pawn he's opened up a square for his
King it has come at the cost of a pawn
but these guys are a bit ugly they're
not the strongest porn structure that
you'd ever like and uh okay the problem
is here is how to attack them can Hikaru
find a way in uh he can drop his Knight
here for example trying to get the rook
in but again a rook trade for Black Will
Save the Day and at the very minimum
instead he just improves his structure
he pushes his Pawn forward Robert it's a
bunch of your ideas kind of combined he
wants to uh keep this one on tap for
later I'm not sure what the direct
threat is but at least it's at least
tricky for Magnus to keep control over
both sides of the wood if the clocks
were reversed I would say a car has some
chances but unfortunately from he's down
on time he's down a pawn he can't
actually quite weasel his way through
and create an attack uh the white king
at some moment may slide up to G4 just
to put pressure on the G5 Pawn to keep
that Knight honest but you receive
magnus's last move he slides his Rook
over to C8 he says I might not just have
to sit passively maybe I'll push my C
Pawn open up my Rook you have to be
careful when doing that because the C6
Pawn is covering the very important D5
square but Magnus he's just not going to
sit and do nothing he's just saying you
have to think about these things if
you're Hikaru not just that he could
also Advance the beep on off the board
and really kicking that Knight out of C4
and then going for the idea of C5 as
well opening up the C file with the
backward Pawn on C3 that Bond sacrifice
that Hikaru just made it's just like
desperate times called for desperate
measures I don't really see where it's
leading yes you create a nice little
spot for your king but Black magnus's
Knight just defends all the pawns all
the weaknesses on the board and also
Watch Out imagine that King does land
there uh David at some point there could
be a potential Checkmate as well you
might hit that Rook on F4 if it could
magically get there somehow would
actually be a meat I love how you're
actually drawing all the arrows to show
the path but it's a possibility that you
need to watch out for and even if that
doesn't happen where is this King headed
it just looks like Magnus has won a pawn
but what better option did Hikaru have
yeah it's about the clock times as
Robert mentions as well this one is not
looking very promising right now I still
don't think white should lose with best
player I think you're okay here despite
giving up that pawn for not too much but
uh Hikaru how does he at least ask one
or two more final questions uh your
plant on the board Tanya that night
kicked back
soon as you have to start retreating oh
look at that that is class that is just
a whole different class you know he
doesn't want to move that c Pawn
creating weaknesses in the center
instead he liquidates the queen Side by
advancing the other pawn and now the
Rook will slide back creating another
weakness for white down on the a file
that A2 Pawn this is why it's called the
Magnus touch yeah
aggressive play Hikaru meanwhile with a
really creative night Retreat he's
holding things together and I'm not sure
Magnus wants to actually rush and
recapture that white a pawn because
there might be an annoying night jump
okay he has gone in now White's Knight
is going to go over watch out for some
Forks some checks but no Magnus steps
out of all the problems all of the
tricks and hikaru's Knight is caught in
two minds if it goes forward and takes
upon Black's root gets active snaps off
the white A2 pawn and unfortunately you
have to make a decision your car only
with two minutes needing a win but now
Black's Rook is active and
that's uh still nowhere near a win for
weight he looks annoyed Hikaru Nakamura
hope is running out here is the
tournament trophy that uh probably
Magnus Carlsen will win and uh you can
also get this trophy it's up for bidding
a unique trophy each tournament in the
Champions chest tour 2023.
oh oh
that's that moves almost as nice as that
trophy he just gives that pawn where two
white pieces can take it and now he's
saying if you take with the King your
king lost contact with the pawn that's
behind on F2 thank you very much if you
take with a pawn black Springs free and
outside pass pawn and some night checks
I wasn't expecting that move I was
listening to Kyle and suddenly I saw
them who played and I was just taken
aback that is beautiful tactical
awareness from Magnus Carlsen he is
really earning this Championship it's a
finishing offense style hair minus he is
and I love Robert's reaction because
every true chess player when they see a
move like that it's like oh just oh yeah
you gotta appreciate it and uh that's
what we call an invisible move when uh
you land something on a square that
looks like it's protected multiple times
it looks impossible but uh often that
breaks the coordination in the enemy
Army and look at your car the bar yeah
he's got a lost position and uh he knows
it unfortunately suddenly too many
problems that white Seaport is about to
fall off with a nasty check that black H
porn as Robert pointed out running down
the board racing down to promotion soon
actually it's almost resignable gotta
say not just that there's another
problem the Knight can jump into the
play by giving a check to the king and
really creating all kinds of forks and
attacks just amazing board Vision here
by Magnus firstly breaks on the queen
side and then on the king side
sacrificing a pawn and this just looks
like we have a result we have a winner
Magnus Carlson takes it he wins the air
things Monsters the very first event in
the Champions chess store 2023 we do see
a smile on his face and what a battle
it's been and what a fighty car Nakamura
has put on
making it all the way to the Grand Final
but today Magnus Carlsen was too strong
he finishes it off and this is the car
looking over the game how impressed are
you with the Magnus in the tournament
though Robert he played amazing chess I
mean there was that one slip up against
our generic Garcia he lost that game and
he almost lost game three today but he
showed his resolve he was able to hold
game three and in game four he really
had no problems he's that strong if you
don't make the most of your chances you
may only get one and then he's going to
become the champion yeah Magnus Carlsen
he uh wins two games in a huge final the
dream final against Hikaru Nakamura how
impressed are you Tanya he was Flawless
today start to finish he took his
chances when Hikaru got too risky he
never gave him a chance to come back and
even the one game that he was on the
defense that big game three that big
Hikaru opportunity he really showed
amazing resilience a completely deserves
this win hasn't lost a single match
throughout amazing play this is why he's
the world champion yeah what has been
the key to magnus's success uh David
it's just that consistency even when he
has one bad game even if he plays one
bad move he pulls himself together it's
just that recovery Factor as well the
bounce back ability that we talk about
uh Magnus just never looks flustered and
compared to some of the other top Rivals
I mean shout out to Hikaru who played
really well this tournament I've got to
say but compared to those other guys he
just has another level to go up to and
it felt like Magnus activated that level
today and uh took the match I want to
join buy Magnus Carlsen winner of the
air things monsters big big
congratulations Magnus
thank you finishing off in style here
and starting off the Champions chat
store season with a big win what does
this mean to you
yeah it's a little bit weird
um
since
I don't really feel like I did much at
all this tournament so I I mean uh
I I mean I won I usually like you win
preliminaries you win a lot of
matches but this time it felt like you
know you're playing matches from the
start suddenly I was in the final and um
out of my last nine games I won one of
them and I won the tournament so it
feels a little bit weird also since
didn't feel like I managed to play close
to my best level but yeah of course
feeling winning feels great yeah and I
have to say it's been even if there
hasn't been a lot of decided games it's
been a lot of entertainment so after
this first event in the Champions chess
store 23 with a whole new format what's
your verdict on this new Champions chat
store
yeah it's certainly it certainly leads
to
um
to uh you know a lot of close close
matches
um the armageddons and their the bidding
and and all of that adds another layer
um frankly for me it's sort of the most
exciting part of the tournament was the
qualifiers I think that's really
um really something good we had for for
this for this year that you really have
to to work hard to to get into the
tournament at all or most players do
um yeah ask for
uh as for the tournaments uh I think the
format is is okay but overall
personally I'm a little bit on under
underwhelmed
um since I didn't feel like uh the
tournament ever really got going in in
in in that sense uh but
um I think uh there will be uh we'll
we'll be more excitement to come for
sure yeah interesting and while we do
know for sure not that in event two
we're gonna see you have qualified
Hikaru has qualified Wesley so has
qualified and Fabiano cariana has
qualified for winning division two today
plus four other players that will go
through from qualifiers so it should be
an exciting event too
yeah it just means that the qualifiers
will be easier
but I think it's it's really good that
we we have um
the sort of the cream of the crop
playing in in these events it's it's
really good to to see and I have to say
for ikara as well uh I know that uh he's
been
fighting through some some difficult
stuff in this tournament with his family
and I think he'll agree as well
um
that
uh he didn't manage to to show his best
level but the fact that he still gets he
still gets through the quarterfinal uh
sorry qualifier and then all the way to
uh the final and makes it uh makes it
close that's um a Real Testament to his
uh
uh to his strengths of character and
also uh how how good it is definitely
and Magnus congratulations on this big
win I just want to get your thoughts in
today's game now after you won game one
it looked like this was going to be a
very tough task for Hikaru but in that
game three there were a lot of
turnarounds that happened and you were
on the back foot in that end game were
you worried at any point
yeah I mean I thought I was completely
lost
I mean I just
couldn't
um like pull myself together in time and
the thing is when you're playing three
seconds uh compared to 10 you don't
really have time at all so I was playing
on the Instinct but my instincts weren't
working so that was extremely
unpractical like I I spent all of that
time trying to find a win and then I
thought I'll bail out into a draw but I
know of course from experience and
everybody knows that when playing
playing him and people know that I'm
playing me as well is that
there as long as you kind of force the
draw then you're not gonna get the draw
you know
um then you really have to to earn it
and I didn't do it and uh you should
have um you should have won the game
and Magnus you're a huge sports fan
yesterday was a day off we following the
NBA trade deadline and do you have any
uh fun insights from what you think is
going to happen in the remainder of the
Season
yeah it was fun too
uh to follow I was also watching the the
Lakers box game uh yesterday
um
so uh yeah uh I think
things have shaken up quite uh quite a
bit so uh I I was considering
um
considering you know taking a trip to
the playoffs this year and my thought
was going uh
going east for sure but now the West
looks a little bit more interesting and
asked my my friend barsa said earlier
today
um maybe Phoenix isn't the worst place
to be in uh in May in June so we'll see
and uh Magnus key question how are you
going to celebrate now
oh I don't know it's so early in the day
you know
I think I'll uh grab the grab a bite to
eat first of all say hi to the boys and
then then we'll see
because we had a challenge for the
experts in the studio and the viewers
today to uh bet what the lowest bid in a
potential Armageddon would be now we
didn't get normal get on but can I ask
you if you uh would have gone to
Armageddon What would have been your bid
today
we'll see you next time
can you give me like issue number so I
have something to finish off the
competition
truth be told uh I hadn't thought about
it at all
um I really
wanted to to finish the match off before
then all right uh actually uh
like
after the surviving the third game I was
pretty confident
um since I didn't think it sort of
uh I feel like that was his his chance
like both against Muslim is he's not had
a lot of chances to win so I thought
that was that was it and also Eric sort
of he told me that now you have to play
an Armageddon with 15 minutes
uh
so I thought yeah uh
yeah that was my Armageddon today
very cool mine is huge congratulations
for uh from all of us for winning the
air things monsters
thank you thank you for joining us and
have fun celebrating
we're also joined by Hikaru Nakamura who
gave it a good fight today Hikaru a
super tough task you had to win two
matches against Magnus today what was it
like
yeah I mean uh the match was really came
down to a couple of critical moments I
mean I think in the first game I just
put my knight on the wrong square and I
mean it's kind of crazy that putting the
Knight on the wrong sport basically led
to me getting a horrible position but
you know I put this Knight on A5 instead
of E7 and game one and then after that I
mean it was just it was difficult maybe
a computer could have found some better
ways to play it but I thought that
Magnus played very principle and I I
mean I just uh was a very clean win from
after that
um you know I think really if that's
what the match came down to I wouldn't
be super upset but obviously in game
three Magnus gave me uh some chances
pretty unnecessarily and I mean it was a
little bit unfortunate that I wasn't
able to win that game I mean I had a
minute against 10 seconds and I was up
the pawn and probably winning somehow in
the real component ending but I mean
Magnus defended very well and that
really was was the chance and after that
I mean okay white in the fourth game but
really uh when you you messed up a
winning position then it's a must win
the fourth game it wasn't wasn't there
so yeah it wasn't meant to be but that's
that's how it goes sometimes yeah and my
this did say in the interview here that
he thought you would agree that neither
of you sort of showed your very best
chess uh both today and in your match on
Wednesday would you agree with that
I mean I I was listening a little bit to
what Magna said I mean I'm trying to
think of a nice way of putting this but
yeah somehow the whole event felt uh it
felt very strange I mean it seemed like
I mean my match against Wesley came down
to one game Magnus the first match also
came down in one game this match today
it came down to like one critical moment
or two critical moments both in game one
and game three and yeah somehow it
seemed um it seemed weird like it didn't
feel like a normal tournament
um compared to say when I played in 2020
or 2021 so yeah I was it was it was all
it was all a little bit strange for me
too
um uh yeah just it felt it felt like
you're you're kind of playing but you're
also not really playing so yeah I don't
I don't I don't know what else to say
really other than it was just uh it all
just felt a little bit weird yeah but
again I will say it has been super
entertaining and Magnus was also saying
that is very impressed with with the
also your character because we know
you've been going through some uh tough
things this uh this week hasn't been a
tough week for you
yeah I mean of course but I'll talk
about that another day but you know I
think the more important point is that I
mean I I think I can say this since I
don't play every term in the world is
that I mean the big difference between
me now and say the me of like let's just
say 20 2014 to 2019 just to use a time
period uh it's pretty much that I don't
just give up I find a way to keep going
and I mean I think in the past very
easily I I would have just gone to the
third game and I would have lost this
game also with black and you know the
match is over very quickly and I think
um that's probably the biggest thing for
me is I found a way to just sort of keep
keep playing keep keep moving forward
and not really worrying about anything
else and I thought today was a great
example I mean I lost the match but to
have that chance in game three
especially after losing the first game
when it all could have gone downhill um
you know I think I'm quite happy with
that I mean again I didn't win the match
but there were a lot of positives to
take away from it so yes you you just
keep fighting you keep trying to play
well and uh it's certainly it's fun to
play against somebody like Magna so I
enjoy it
right here Carl today didn't go your day
uh way excuse me but you have so many
more events coming up as next we're
going to see from you in the Pro chess
league and title Tuesday
um I guess something like that I mean I
haven't even really thought about any of
those things actually
um yeah it's again it's very weird
because as I said this event it was like
it was so short somehow and there were
so many matches that I again I'm not
trying to be rude here but there were so
many matches I felt very very boring
many of the games were very boring not
just mine
um and so like I I somehow I guess I am
looking forward to the protesting and
title Tuesday a little bit more because
I think everybody will take more chances
too I mean I I think when you're playing
the best players in the world for the
most part you have to be pretty solid
you can't take huge risks with uh with
black in particular so uh yeah I'm
looking forward to title Tuesday in the
protest League
um and yeah we'll see we'll see what
else I have but yeah it's you just take
it one one event at a time but do you
think the next event will be tougher but
because we do know you will play Magnus
Wesley and now today also Fabiano Carana
qualified for event two
well I mean I don't have to play all of
them thankfully um that's the first
thing because I think you can only lose
two matches so I I mean I won't play all
of them uh but you know to me I I think
that's that's kind of uh that's that's a
good thing because if I'm being honest I
think even Magnus would probably I'm not
saying he wouldn't qualify but I think
even Magnus would have would have a big
uphill battle trying to qualify from the
qualifiers I think if you have to plan
that there's really no guarantee for
anybody that you'll make it through I
mean we saw many great players like
napoleonchi aronian Etc and I mean they
didn't even qualify so I think just not
having to play the qualifier is is
already is is already amazing and um so
like knowing that I have to like play
against magnets for probably on our
Wesley like yeah I I don't care that's
that's just uh it's just good that I'm
in the event to begin with yeah and uh
finally Hikaru I've had a competition
for the experts in the studio and for
the viewers today to bet the winning bid
in a potential Armageddon now obviously
we didn't get Norma get on but can I ask
you what would you have been today if we
did see an arm again at all I mean the
just like Magnus I I I'm not going to
answer that in the main reason I'm not
going to answer that is because I'll say
with like 99 certainty there's going to
be another Armageddon that that we play
in the next event or two and and
honestly I mean you can keep bidding
lower and lower but there comes a point
where you in your mind you know what the
absolute lowest time that you can go to
is and so you just say it then
everyone's going to know that so I mean
I I don't have anything in mind
um
but I would say probably somewhere close
to what I've been against Wesley okay
something close to that something close
to that Hikaru thank you so much for
giving us a lot of entertainment this
week and uh for giving us an interview
thank you
no problem see you guys soon see you
guys yep all right uh okay so we didn't
get an answer to
the bidding should we then use uh the
bids that we had between these two in
the winners Final on Wednesday ah I wish
I wish I'd known that otherwise
at 8 59. okay yeah we can use that okay
Hikari said closer to the one he bit
against Wesley that was 805. yeah we're
gonna go with the one that he played
against magnets
because that is the only answer we got
actually eight it's funny because I
split the difference so you know I'm
right around the middle of those two
okay we're gonna go with 805. because I
don't remember what you guys said we're
gonna go with 805 which was the lowest
bid we had in Armageddon during the air
things monsters what's the price for
this uh yeah what is the prize well
we're going to the good night to
celebrate let's do it a glass of
something good is the price so we have
Robert betting 8 29 oh but David's
beating you because 8 14. Ivanka 8 30
eight and tanya901.
David you are the winner of the
Armageddon competition
it's been a lot of fun with the
Armageddon wouldn't you say it has I
like this new bidding process and I
think it might become more standard
place I'm not sure whether that will
happen in few Day events but I'd love to
see it in World Cups and the like in
future it's definitely added to the
drama yeah and we're gonna find a winner
uh from the viewers as well
uh the closest to 805 will get this
error thanks device signed by Magnus
Carlsen himself uh but before we reveal
that let's take a look at the bracket
the other things monsters is over we
started out with some exciting
quarterfinals in the winner is
semi-final Magnus Carlsen knocked are
you guys see down to the losers bracket
Hikaru Nakamura knocked Wesley so down
to the losers bracket in their winners
final Magnus will not match to make it
straight through to the Grand Final he
car Nakamura later joined him but it was
a big match win for Magnus today to win
the air things monster starting off the
Champions gesture season in fantastic
let's take a look also at the results
from division two the winner of division
two would secure a spot in division one
in the next event in Fabiano caruana he
won that match against you youngie and
is ready for division one in the next
CCT event division three was uh decided
yesterday the Grand Final was played
between Sam Seville and pragna number
and it was a match win four some Savion
as an American happy to see that Robert
you know I'm not feeling overly
patriotic at the moment but it's great
to see the young star Sam Serbian he did
really well in the Chester come Global
Championship it's great to see him do
well in the championship tour and we'll
probably see him in a higher division
the next time around yeah yeah I agree
uh we also have to take a look at the
Tour leaderboard
you get points in each event
according to your results and Magnus
Carlsen is on top of course with 150
points sikara Nakamura with a hundred
points and then a bunch of fantastic
players coming in behind there there are
a total of six events in the CCT this
season before it all finishes off with a
big championship and uh they also get a
lot of money 235
000 is the total prize fund for the air
things monsters and Magnus Carlsen takes
home today thirty thousand dollars
twenty thousand dollars for Hikaru
Nakamura
it's been a great event it's been a fun
day even if we didn't get Armageddon but
we did get a puzzle from Ivanka today
her favorite puzzle and it's time to
reveal the answer Ivanka yes certainly
is and uh it's a study by Yuri dorgov
and uh I love this puzzle so much now
obviously black has two queens but the
king is in trouble and a lot of you got
the first move right that is simply for
the night to go to C7 and get give a
check to the king and uh the next move
is forced Queen takes Knight
and then comes the critical point you
push the pawn and give a check to the
king and now the king steps forward to
see four square and if you do notice the
king doesn't actually have too many
squares to travel to you can travel to
B3 and can travel to D5 and this is
where things get very very spicy the
queen comes to G8 as many of you saw and
Black's best actually is for the queen
to go to F7 and just give herself away
but that really doesn't save anything
because after Queen takes Queen and once
the queen comes to D5 it's going to be a
winning King and pawn ending for white
but this is the key point and this is
why it gets is basically in my top
top puzzle ever is because black will
actually play Queen to D5 blocking the
check and here comes it's so beautiful
the king will move to C2 black you know
white completely forgets about the queen
and says take it take the queen and so
black says yes thank you very much and
now here it comes the pawn comes to E4
taking away the last square that the
king can go to and just take a look at
those two black queens they cannot do a
single thing to prevent the pawn coming
to B3 and giving a wonderful checkmate
chess Beauty simply there was there a
lot of viewers who got it right Ivanka
there were a few views he got it right
with a big smile as well but a lot of
people saw the fact that the first saw
the first two moves fantastic simply
chess uh Beauty you guys now it's gonna
take us some time to figure out who was
closest to 805 in the bidding
competition so you'll have to check out
who the winner is uh following the
Champions chest for account on Twitter
one lucky winner will get this signed
everything's device signed by Magnus
Carlsen now the next event in the
Champions Chester it starts April 3rd
and we host qualifiers every week four
title players that actually means you
guys
could play the qualifiers will you it
sounds like a bit of fun sounds like a
challenge why not but you can't qualify
because I repeat you guys in the studio
that's the only reason I wouldn't
qualify for sure
no but is there any chance you guys will
just give it a chance oh maybe yeah I
mean I think the initial qualifiers are
for non-grandmasters and then you know
they work their way up to the Swiss and
then the playing uh but I think you know
the tournament is great because of this
everyone has a chance to qualify uh
everyone has a chance to win and as
Fabiano caruana said he's playing people
he's not used to playing who are very
very strong some up and comers or some
people who have been around hovering
just below the top tier for a while but
can beat those elite players in any
given match so I do think this
democratic meritocratic system is a
great one
and uh we didn't see too many women in
the qualifiers before the air things
monsters Tanya would like to see some
more women well this time it was only
open to Grand Masters and there are not
those many women players who have the
full title we did see one tanzongi play
and she had a phenomenal run in fact she
was also playing in the women Grand Prix
at the same time finishing her match
there then she came in for the Swiss
qualifiers and she finished in the
second division had a brilliant play
throughout but I would love to see more
female players are participating I'm
happy doing the commentary and watching
it but this time I think it's for all
title players so International Masters
can also play yep yeah I'm gonna play
that one then okay cool the next chance
for all Titan players is February 13th
and on February 14th the day after
finally the protest league is back that
is super exciting where it worked it is
and we started Cara Nakamura say there's
nothing he loves more on Valentine's Day
than playing some chess so hopefully
we'll see him him in the protest League
it's such a great event rare to have a
team event in chess outside the Olympia
David knows a thing or two about success
in team events but it is great it feels
like a lot of fun because you're not
doing just for yourself but for your
teammates yeah you do enjoy the team
events David I do and I can confirm I've
signed up for a team in the process
league so uh yeah I can't wait awesome
all right I'm looking forward to
watching and I'm also looking forward to
event two in the Champions chess tour it
starts the main event starts on April
3rd this was the first one on chess.com
first Champions chat store 2023 event
it's been so much fun a lot of drama
with Armageddon already looking forward
to the next one a big thank you to
everyone who's been with us for sharing
your thoughts and questions on Twitter
and twitch we hope to see you again in
the future but for now have a good one
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]